[Music]
you
you're listening to radio Sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
welcome to the Open University of the
airwaves with George Galloway only on
Sputnik radio after weeks in which it
sometimes seemed the United States was
about to declare war on China this
weekend all the guns have switched back
to Russia turns out that the Taliban
were only waiting for some Russian
rubles before they took a potshot or two
at us and even UK troops in the
occupation of Afghanistan which has now
gone on longer than the first and second
world wars put together in fact twice
the length in fact more than that
it's a crazy hypothesis which I intend
to explore and having spent the last few
weeks turning their guns on the statue
of slavers the black lives matter
movement are now targeting Abraham
Lincoln who freed the slaves go figure
as they say in the United States of
America Rebecca long Billy the left-wing
challenger to Circular star ma for
leader of the Labour Party is no more
was she ever but now she is a martyr
what's going to happen next in the
British Labour Party as Benjamin
Netanyahu prepares to annex most of the
Palestinian West Bank pierced armor has
launched a war against his own party
members standing up for the victims of
that illegal theft of land and the
occupation of Palestine there's lots to
talk about tonight it's going to be a
bumpy ride so fasten your seat belts
this is a radio show but with pictures
stay tuned
radio Sputnik we speak your language the
mother of all talk shows the only
education you can get free
[Music]
George Galloway
this is radio Sputnik and this is London
but coming to you of course all over the
world thanks to the wonders of the
internet and Sputnik news.com
we're on FM in the Washington DC area
big audience building up there by the
way on 105.5 on FM and you can listen on
am across the united states from sea to
shining sea from burning city to burning
city you can listen online of course at
Sputnik news.com and hundreds of
thousands of you are listening on these
platforms but more than half a million
of you for the tenth straight week in a
row are watching as well as listening
the mother of all talk shows a truly
global audience a global university of
the airwaves and if you're watching on
facebook then please share it with all
of your friends all of your contacts on
Facebook we intend to make the regular 1
million audience by the end of this year
with your help
god willings you can watch on my
facebook page george galloway official
bluetick or on any of Arty's multiple
facebook platforms ditto on youtube you
can watch on my youtube channel george
galloway official and do subscribe while
you're there there's plenty of good
stuff on there or on our T's multiple
YouTube channels you can even watch on
Twitter and on Instagram well however
you are watching or listening we've got
a show for you tonight because it's hard
to keep up with the news as it develops
increasing levels new dimensions of
absurdity of atrocity are being reached
across the world let me start with the
absurdity inside the British Labour
Party somebody called Rebecca long Billy
that nobody outside of Britain will ever
have held off and hardly anyone in
Britain
has ever held off she was the left-wing
carbon supporting candidate although
supporting him as the Rope supports the
hanging man by the end she was if you
like the continuity Corbin candidate
just here four months ago against the
Blair right candidate turkey or star nor
the British states former chief
prosecutor what could possibly go wrong
anyway she was heavily defeated but
given a consolation prize a low profile
portfolio they thought as the shadow
education secretary certainly they
didn't allow her to talk much about
education not least because she
supported by the teaching trade unions
thought that rushing our children back
to school in the middle of our color
coronavirus pandemic was a bad idea so
they sent our other Blair I lieutenants
to talk about schools more often than
she was able to be but then unwisely she
retweeted an article from the
independent newspaper that's owned by
the former KGB rezident in London whom I
knew well no I'm saying he now owns the
independent newspaper and they published
a splendid article by an actress called
Maxine Peake a bit of an icon actually
in left-wing politics in Britain in
which on passing she mentioned that many
US police departments were learning
their brutal tactics in Israel where
they were going not making this up
American cops going to Israel for
training in how to subdue a recalcitrant
and did I say
occupied population now this all had the
benefit of being indisputably true in
fact the Minneapolis Police Department
posted on their website about the
training they had received
in Israel the virtual Jewish library has
given extensive coverage to this new
practice of many US police forces
obtaining training in Israel it is a
matter of public record in Israel in the
Journal of public record in Israel
Haaretz on umpteen occasions and this
was mentioned by Maxine Peake in her
article which the independent published
and this was retweeted by Rebecca long
Billy Moore I think as a tribute to her
distinguished constituent Maxine Peake
and within hours she was sacked by
circus Tama from the labor front bench
does that constitute a porch without a
doubt because she was the last Carbonite
standing on the labor front bench in the
shadow cabinet and so in just a few
months labor has gone from having a
Jeremy Corbyn John McDonald leadership
at Corbin McDonald dominated national
executive a front bench dominated by
carbon and McDonald in just three months
to the complete opposite Blair ISM is
back just when you thought it was safe
to get back in the water
however this poses a major problem now
for Kirsten mer first of all because he
defined what Maxine Peake said in this
article which by the way the independent
having published then congratulated star
MA for sacking someone for retweeting
their article so much for the Western
media about which more later I promise
you but the problem for stormer is that
the conflation of criticism of the
israeli police force with Judaism as
anti-semitism is itself and
Semitic and someone has now tabled an
official complaint in the Labour Party's
complaints procedure accusing Kearse
Tama of anti-semitism this one will run
and run the second problem is that mr.
Netanyahu is next week this week coming
going to rip up 50 years of
international law rip up the Oslo
agreement rip up the absurdly named
peace process and officially confiscate
bringing into Israel the land that
Israel has occupied on the west bank of
the River Jordan ever since 1967 53
years a long time in anybody's life time
and so labor members are now in a
situation where they will be forced to
remain silent about this atrocity that
mr. Netanyahu intends to pursue against
the wishes of every government in the
whole world except the government of
Donald J Trump and Jared Kushner and so
I'm asking in this poll number one is
the Labour Party engaged in a purge a
yes B no you can vote now on my Twitter
page but it is a purge and it is an
invitation a to self-censorship the
arrow that flies in the night you don't
see it but it reaches its target
nonetheless labor members are now living
under a reign of intellectual terror on
the subject of Israel Palestine and how
many of them are going to be purged if
they step out of line how many of them
my experience this week rather a lot are
going to rip up their labor party cards
rather than wait to be picked off one by
one so that's one of the subjects that
will
dealing with this evening of course the
coronavirus crisis continues apace in
Britain an average of a hundred and
forty people die every day of the corona
virus if 140 people died every day from
a terrorist attack well it would be the
biggest story in the country but it
isn't here because our government has
declared effectively that the crisis is
over except that it isn't the first wave
isn't less than 10% of our people have
caught the corona virus yet and 65
thousand of us have died as a result do
the maths when 20 percent of us have got
it if 50 percent of us get it and the
death rates rise exponentially well we
are in the mother of all public health
crises but you wouldn't think it does
the March going on in settling down
right now for black trans rights I think
it says though there are virtually no
black people on it and I didn't see that
many trans people none that stood out
anyway but thousands of people in close
proximity with no social distancing are
out demonstrating in Britain again today
and half a million people reportedly
crammed onto the beach at Bournemouth in
the week on the hottest day of the year
have no idea where they went to the
toilet but half a million people is a
lot of coronavirus and a lot of litter
and trash so we'll be talking about
what's next on the corona virus with
Ranjit bra doctor physician surgeon as
always in the third hour of the mother
of all talk shows this evening it's
still rampant in the United States in
one state after another this week
figures of increases of hundreds of
percent
of cases is being reported I work every
night on Rt America and just before I
come on I hear the roundup Texas Florida
all kinds of places
Trump territory by the way is suffering
voting increases in the number of people
with coronavirus but still Trump pushes
on the heat didn't do what he said it
would do the drugs that he's punted
didn't do what he said they would do but
actually now the corona virus may be the
least of his problems that and the
collapsing economy in the United States
is definitely placing a gigantic
question mark now on his ability to be
reelected in November the only saving
grace for Donald Trump is that the man
the Democrats are put up against them is
a man that isn't fit to be let out alone
and isn't allowed out alone
in fact he isn't allowed out at all he
presumably scripted delivers homilies
into a camera in his basement in his
house in Delaware now if he can get all
the way to the election that way he
might have a chance of doing it he
hasn't had a press conference since he
was chosen as the presumptive candidate
for the Democratic Party if he ever does
have to face the press and when he has
to face the hundreds of millions of
dollars of attack ads which the Trump
camp are going to launch at him he may
crumble under the pressure we'll see but
in any case a new front opened up this
weekend and I have to deal with it in
the next few minutes after what seems
like months of China being public enemy
number one
suddenly it's back to Russia
according to the New York Times
confirmed by the Washington Post and the
other major newspapers in the United
States the Taliban have been taking the
ruble taking the Rubbo from President
Putin as payment for bunty for the
killing of occupation troops no
scintilla of evidences offered of the
stories are based entirely on briefings
from inside the US intelligence
community with each newspaper speaking
presumably to the same spooks and
plastering it over their front page and
now when I looked earlier before the
show the charge of treason is being
leveled again at president Donald Trump
because they say he knew that this was
being done and said and did nothing
about it
now there are a number of problems with
this story
the first one is anybody who thinks the
Taliban need Russian money to fire shots
American occupiers hasn't been paying
attention to the history over the last
nearly 40 years of Afghan history they
really know nothing about it you see the
Afghan people have been fighting foreign
armies on their soil since 1980 and
before that centuries before that were
fighting every foreign army they arrived
in their country from Alexander the
Great all the way to George W Bush not
so great they didn't require foreign
funding to do so it's stretching it a
bit that they would require foreign
funding to do it now but that's not the
only problem with the hypothesis a
bigger problem is the Taliban are not
killing American or British soldiers at
all there's a ceasefire there's a peace
process the Taliban are fighting the
public Afghan government forces not the
foreign forces although the foreign
forces are still fighting them from the
sky a third problem and the biggest of
all is this there was a foreign funder
of the Islamist fanatics
in Afghanistan but it was not Russia
in fact the Russians were the victims of
it it was the United States of America
I've just watched two brilliant
interviews given by Hillary Clinton no
less in which she describes in great
detail how the United States poured
money material men propaganda into
building up the Islamist monster in
Afghanistan with the precise purpose of
killing Russians so this story turns on
its absolute head actually reverses the
actual reality which is that the people
who paid the Taliban the people who paid
al-qaeda the people who paid Isis the
people who paid every one of the
alphabet soup of Islamist extremist
organizations over the last decades was
not Russia which was actually fighting
them on the battlefield in Syria while
we were there Air Force and their chief
propagandists this Islamist monster is
the creation of not Russia but the
United States itself so
so much for governments and politicians
Liars almost everyone but what does it
say about the Western media every single
one of which across the entire Western
world has repeated this baseless fact
free idiotic charge against Russia today
on their front pages and on their news
bulletins what it says is we don't have
a free media at all we have a collection
of higher higher Ling's whose job is to
be the stenographer of the power in the
country in which they are operating
which is the exact adverse of what
journalism is supposed to do and be
which might explain why Julian Assange
continues to languish in Britain's
Guantanamo Bay a Belmarsh prison in
South London this is the mother of all
talk shows there's much more of this
over the next 2 hours and 40 minutes
this is the mother
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
tune in every Thursday - loud and clear
with Brian Becker for the regular
segment called veterans for peace where
we focus on the contemporary issues of
war and peace that affect veterans their
families the country and the world as a
whole
veterans for peace president Gerry
Condon joins the show every Thursday
hear about this and more every Thursday
right here on radio Sputnik we are above
all the latest developments and we don't
take any sides Radio Sputnik telling the
untold
the mother of all talk shows with George
Galloway the world is our classroom and
you're welcome to sit in and join the
seminar is the Labour Party engaged in a
purge a yes 82% be no 18% you can vote
now on my Twitter page four hundred and
nine people have done so in the first
few minutes of the show now Rania Khalek
is always a welcome and popular guest
here on the mother of all talk shows
she's a journalist a TV presenter a
writer and an all-round expert on what's
happening in the United States I'm glad
to see she joins us now Rania welcome
back to the mother of all talk shows you
grace us with your wonderful presence
thank you again for coming now let's
start with this insanity that has swept
the United States media in which it
turns out that the warlike Taliban were
only prepared to shoot American soldiers
if the Russians paid them to over to you
the New York Times broke the story that
was so obviously planted by US
intelligence officials they literally
say throughout the piece according to
unnamed US intelligence officials over
and over over again saying you know
America the the Russians were giving out
bounties to the Taliban to kill US
troops it was like usual accepted as
gospel by the rest of the American
corporate media and they've all been
running with it despite the fact that
it's based on you know the the claims of
unnamed officials just like a rock WMDs
were based on these claims of officials
and was really fascinating about this is
like you mentioned you know as if the
Taliban needed to be given an incentive
a monetary incentive to attack the
Americans since the Americans
Afghanistan in 2001 there has been an
ongoing insurgency against the foreign
occupier nobody needs to pay this
insurgency it's been ongoing and what's
even more interesting about this is in
so many ways
it's projection because this is actually
what the US did in the 1980s I'm sure
many of your viewers you know know that
in the 1980s the u.s. armed and funded a
Islamic Islamic militant groups in the
shayateen to try and overthrow the
Soviet backed government in Afghanistan
and so they were actually earning and
paying Islamic militants Afghanistan to
kill Russian soldiers
so perhaps as part of that projection is
to turn it around and blame it on them
but then there's also the curious timing
of this right the fact that that Russia
is actually coordinating peace talks
right now between the us-backed Afghan
government and the Taliban that set to
take place and Cutler that's that's the
ongoing as we speak so there is an
agenda behind this sort of gossip that's
being spread by the media right now with
just to sabotage those peace talks and
no one seems to be taking that in mind
there's also this other aspect of it
where you kind of see an attempt to
resurrect the Russia gate hysteria
there's like an entire grifting
apparatus in place of all these people
who made lots of money spreading the
Russia gate area and even though it was
false now that that's faded away this is
another way for people to get back on TV
and to sell their their Russian game
books again is to rev up this narrative
so there's all kinds of things wrapped
up in this news story that so far
doesn't actually have any verification
to it we have a kind of schizophrenia at
work here the the right of American
politics has gone completely bananas
against China kung flu although it turns
out actually may be started in Barcelona
of all places the Spanish flu wasn't
Spanish but the confluent to have these
Spanish the right is berserk against
China
the so-called left the Democrats and the
liberal media is berserk about Russia
all the while your people are going down
like flies with coronavirus and your
economy is going down the tube and this
is the most obvious national convulsion
of look over there that I think any of
us have ever seen running a hundred
percent and you know you and I times
last few months and every time I come on
to coronavirus situation and the u.s.
gets worse and it's gotten so bad to the
point where nobody even cares anymore
oh you know a hundred I don't even know
how many Americans at this point died a
couple weeks ago is 120,000 people don't
even pay attention to the number anymore
we have more cases in a day yesterday
then we've had since the spires started
it's it's incredible it's the officials
in this country have given up they don't
care we're just we're we don't have a
wave in America we've got this like
tsunami that's just an ongoing you know
the tip of the tsunami the peak is just
phase peaking it's normal now and people
are angry people are also jobless people
over 30 million people in America have
lost their jobs because of the lockdown
from the pandemic and you know a lot of
those unemployment benefits are about to
run out and you also have this this mass
uprising across the country up against
police brutality that took place over
the past month which is pretty
unprecedented in the u.s. at least in my
lifetime to see protests like this
across the country so a lot is happening
there's only unrest in America right now
and there's more unrest on the horizon
if things don't change and rather than
actually change the system of mass and
equality that's only getting worse
because of the pandemic as people are
dying in mass what you see I think is
what you're saying it's time from elites
to also divert attention and that's with
the China hysteria and now the
resurrection of the Russia hysteria but
you know something I noticed is that at
the end of the day Americans aren't
falling for it this time mostly because
their immediate lives are impacted so
deeply by the ramifications of this
virus
don't have time to care about Russia and
China and what US unnamed US
intelligence officials are saying in the
New York Times they're more concerned
about am I gonna be able to pay my rent
am I gonna be able to pay my mortgage
you know am I gonna be able to send my
kids back to school am I gonna have a
job in two months what am I gonna do in
unemployment benefits run out we're not
gonna buy gonna buy food these are the
kinds of things that most Americans are
concerned about right now and the
disconnect I don't think has ever been
more severe than it is right now between
American elites and the general
population and didn't that extraordinary
picture that you just painted the
Democrats have fielded crazy Joe Biden
how is he doing well you know because
Donald Trump is so reviled at the moment
and because his policies have had such a
negative impact the pheno is neglect
over the coronavirus and just the way
he's handled the unrest across the
country with protests by you know being
even more divisive and pull and more
polarizing people you know he's actually
lost a pretty big chunk of support for
now what that means for November you
know we can't really make too many
assumptions right now based on what's
going on and make conclusions about
November but as far as polls go Joe
Biden is doing better but you have to I
mean you have to take into account he's
doing better than Trump because Trump is
so awful um you know Joe Biden is it his
uh he still has really hide to give him
like negativity ratings he's not the
most popular person but at this point
it's kind of like you could run my pinky
finger against Donald Trump and it would
pull better because of how dissatisfied
Americans are with him right now
but I think there's something else
interesting going on in the country as
well as we just had some new primary
elections but the Democrats and
Republicans where people run so they eat
of the ducks in the primary races for
various seats across the country for
Congress and then a couple of those
seats the progressive challenger
actually beat the corporate mainstream
bite and backed candidate we saw that
happen in one in New York 16th district
with jebel Bowman
against eliot engel eliot engel is
probably one of the most Pro warden for
chronic neo cons in Congress and he's
been in Congress since 1989 so that was
a pretty big deal to see him unseated so
I think you're gonna see more of that
going forward night that's where the
more interesting stuff when it comes to
elections is taking place between what's
going on with those sort of more
progressive wing of the Democratic Party
versus the more mainstream wait wait but
in the meantime yeah I mean Trump is
definitely falling in the polls and just
to the benefit of Joe Biden now let me
press you on therefore his vice
presidential pick because with the
president inches from senility even if
Biden does win it can't be long surely
before article 25 is triggered poor old
Joyce described as no longer up to the
job and the vice president then steps in
who was that who would that be
well right now people are talking about
a handful of names that keep being
floated in the media like Stacey Abrams
and Kamala Harris because of the
protests across the country against
police brutality it's rumored that you
know Joe Biden is looking to take a
woman of color which is great right it's
a big milestone to have a woman of color
be vice president should Joe Biden win
however he's of course going to pick
somebody who's as corporate and as
right-wing of a Democrat as he is so at
the end of the day the policies won't
change but the face of those policies
might so that's what we're looking at
right now we're looking at Joe Biden
trying to use identity politics to
appease the sort of progressive wing of
the Democratic Party by saying oh look
that guy kicked a woman of color see I'm
you know I'm progressive to without
actually making any real policy changes
but that's fine I I have no confidence
that he's gonna pick somebody who's
actually progressive he'll pick someone
like Stacey Abrams or Kamala Harris
which is you know these are our
corporate mainstream Democrats who are
just like Joe Biden with a different
base now lastly and I'm grateful for
your time the the protests and the
statues that are being targeted have
begun it seems
reading from here to become more
provocative more controversial more
divisive the ultimate perhaps being the
attempt and the threat to destroy
statues to President Lincoln himself is
that popular amongst the the protesting
classes is there a division about this
kind of thing is this going to run out
of steam do you think there's absolutely
no starting a couple weeks ago and we
saw the elicits grant statue being
pulled down in San Francisco grant was
of course the leader of the Union or the
general who led the unions to defeat the
Confederacy
so there are divisions within protests
about removing statues to people who
represent the side that defeated the
Confederacy and defeated slavery and as
far as the general population I mean the
general population does is not
supportive of the idea of taking down
statues to people like like Lincoln but
I think another day you know it is well
it's nice to see you know in the
immediate aftermath to see statues to
race us being taken down particularly
when its symbols of the Confederacy I
think this is really symbolic and if
that's what people want to focus on fine
but I do think to a degree it does lose
it does take attention away from the
systemic changes that we need when
everything becomes about taking down
statues and memorials you know I'm not
debating whether that's good or bad it's
just a matter of changing the names of
things and taking down statues doesn't
change you know the funding the the
level of funding and militarization of
police it doesn't change the racism and
classism that plagues our system that
leads to police killing people of color
but also other poor people as well that
doesn't change by a Terry now statue so
my concern is not necessarily about the
statutes coming down but more about is
this gonna become the primary focus of
these protests which have a lot of
momentum and have a lot of sympathy
across the country
I certainly hope that's not the case I
really hope that people can you know
keep their eye on the ball which is
actually changing
system that we have rather than just
making cosmetic changes that make us
feel good for a few moments Rania Khalek
always a pleasure to talk to you thanks
for joining us on the mother of all talk
shows from the United States here's the
poll is the Labour Party engaged in a
purge yes 85 percent up to being no 15
percent down to you can vote now on my
Twitter page let me take a 60-second
break I'll be right back
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
tune in every Thursday - loud and clear
with Brian Becker for the regular
segment called veterans for peace where
we focus on the contemporary issues of
war and peace that affect veterans their
families the country and the world as a
whole
veterans for peace president Gerry
Condon joins the show every Thursday
hear about this and more every Thursday
right here on radios button we are above
all the latest developments and we don't
take any sides
Radio Sputnik telling at the untold
the mother of all talk shows with George
Galloway the world is our classroom and
you're welcome to sit in and join the
seminar I suggest you get your calls in
early tonight early signs are that it's
going to be very busy indeed if you're
calling us from the United Kingdom its
Oh two or seven seven nine eight two two
five five that's two or seven seven nine
eight two two five five if you're
calling us from the United States it's
zero zero one seven five seven seven
four four four four eight zero or you
can tweet us of course at George
Galloway or at RT UK news preferably
both now social media comments coming in
thick and fast
Derrida says the labor purge is doomed
to fail that cliff edge this party is
dying to go over I guess we are mere
spectators now watching the stupidity of
a central executive we need a credible
third party now seems to me the need
that in the United States to and he says
it was never about that tweet it's about
shutting down the left and Michael says
definitely although I do think it was
terribly naive of Rebecca long Bailey to
retweet Maxine Peaks interview still
there's no doubt that star Maher and his
cronies are out to eradicate once and
for all
every last reminder of Corbin and on
Instagram an Instagram user says Blair
is a disgrace to the Labor Party and a
Martha says amazing how quickly star
Maher acted on this but hasn't acted on
anything else quite forensic really and
on Twitter Lisa says good morning from
New Zealand George good morning to all
my friends
darn under and on Facebook a JD says
salute to the teacher GG thank you for
that Renee says greetings from Cape Town
South Africa my favorite city in all the
world ran
and Paul says Cork City Ireland here
would be interesting to hear your take
on the current affairs in Irish politics
mr. Galloway look forward to the show
every week
refreshing honest news well the short
takeaway Paul is never trust a green
know in Ireland or more or less anywhere
else that's my take and on YouTube a
user says outdoor protests in the USA
produced 0 new cases of coronavirus
facts well you don't actually provide
any facts mister user only an assertion
that seems contrary to logic look
breaking news here's the FA Cup
semi-final draw it's Manchester United
vs. Jesse Wow or Arsenal against either
Newcastle or Manchester City who are
playing now we'll bring you the score
majesty Narad vs Chelsea at Wembley well
my children will be very happy to hear
it
now look every week I do a short for RT
this week it was about the Venezuelan
gold which the Bank of England is being
tested on in the High Court in London
right now and the verdict may come
tomorrow or perhaps on Tuesday the
government of Venezuela
once it's called back the Bank of
England without even wearing a mask has
decided to steal it
take a look
a battle royal is underway at the High
Court in London over a billion dollars
worth of solid gold the gold of course
belongs to Venezuela and the court is
being asked whether or not it will
accede to the legalization of theft of
international piracy of brigand Rhee
without the robbers even having the
courtesy to wear a mask you may very
well ask why a country like Venezuela
trusted London with its sovereign wealth
unfortunately a very significant number
of countries of the global South have
done so the only alternative I suppose
being the Federal Reserve in the United
States of America which you might think
is marginally less trustworthy or at
least until no the fact that the gold
belongs to Venezuela is not at issue it
can hardly be it was deposited in the
Bank of England by the recognized
government of Venezuela at the time and
the recognized government of Venezuela
at this time wants the money to be sent
to the United Nations in New York for
the development program work on
coronavirus in Venezuela now Venezuela
has done fantastically well in combating
corvid 19 only 4,500 cases have been
recorded and only 45 people have died
from the disease compared to Britain
where 65,000 people have died from the
disease but nonetheless the powerless
economic condition of Venezuela with
poverty malnourishment widespread as a
result of United States and
international sanctions and embargo on
the country is such that the sovereign
government of Venezuela has asked the UN
to administer the funds on their behalf
for the relief of the people what kind
of court what kind of government what
kind of Bank of England I could resist
such a cry from the heart well the
answer is this kind of British
government and this kind of Bank of
England and we'll find out soon well of
this kind of High Court in London is
prepared to legalize the brazen theft of
a billion dollars of gold bullion the
British government is among 50 odd other
governments in the world that recognise
a man in the street called Juan Guido
who appointed himself as the president
of Venezuela but that holds absolutely
no water in international law because
the vast majority of countries in the
world continue to recognize the
legitimate elected government of Nicolas
Maduro and it's his government that
holds the seat in the United Nations
which means international law is on his
side it is completely false for the
British government to claim as they have
claimed that they do not recognize the
government of Nicolas Maduro that's a
lie they recognize him every day when
they're diplomats in New York talk to
his diplomats in New York in the canteen
or in the fora themselves of the United
Nations the sovereign international body
in the world so I'm afraid there is
nothing that the British High Court can
do except allow the legitimate elected
government of Venezuela to have their
money it's not even as if they're asking
for it for themselves
they're asking for it to be sent to the
United Nations and spent by the United
Nations there's nothing the High Court
can do on that unless the High Court
wants to and for all time kill the idea
the other people's sovereign wealth will
be safe in the vaults of the Bank of
England it used to be a thing
when I was growing up it was a phrase as
safe as the Bank of England but a mate
or not in the next day or two that the
Bank of England ain't very safe at all
have something to say do you disagree
with George then call us now and give us
your view is the Labour Party engaged in
a purge eh yes 85% and B no 15 percent
who are the 15 and why don't you think
it's part let's go to the phone lines
first call of the night is George in
Belfast in Ireland go ahead George hi
George I'm a little bit down don't beat
and probably because of the vacuum which
has been created I'm looking at the
political spectrum across the whole of
the world and all I can see to be
perfectly honest is nothing more than a
leaning a push towards the right the
genuine socialist politicians that we
have known and loved are being pushed
away from mainstream that there's an
awful lot of the media which is trying
to get their particular agenda over and
it's isolating an awful lot of people
who at the bottom end of society have
very very few real voices to help them
Ike and I'm no wandering I'm desperate
to think that we cannot we will not have
a socialist government in the United
Kingdom night if I even expand back to
Ireland what has gone on in the Republic
of Ireland is nothing short of a scandal
whenever three disparate parties can
cobble together some kind of a thick
coalition to keep the second largest
party away from the control of
government is absolutely
thus crucial and non democratic and I
weep for democracy I really weep for it
and I don't know what to do well it's a
powerful point Georgia reminded me when
I was thinking about
of what happened to me in the Rhonda
constituency in 1982 in South Wales
where I go I was running to be the
parliamentary candidate there and I got
more nominations than all of the other
candidates put together so the
supporters of all of the other
candidates came together and refused to
put me on the shortlist and that's
exactly what's happened to Shin Fein in
the Irish Republic the party which won
very marginally more members of the
Doyle than them could not form a
government on its own
so it has formed the government with
people that hate its guts but just
happened to hate Shin Fein more and so
you've got a government of the ancient
civil war enemies FINA Foyle and FINA
Gill and kept in power by the green
party of all people the greens are going
to keep the right-wing neoliberal
coalition government in power in Dublin
I don't know if they've got a banning of
plastic bags or some other such
Bagatelle for their Labour's but it will
be no surprise to me if it later turns
out that that's what they have sold
their country for the good news though
is that Mary Lou MacDonald is now the
leader of the Opposition the
unchallengeable and incontestable leader
of the Opposition in Ireland and as I
have zero confidence that this monstre
Hydra headed neoliberal coalition
government in Dublin can do anything to
solve the problems of the people in
Ireland expect that next time round
whenever that is and it might be sooner
than you think George that Shin train
will win a thumping victory indeed if
they put up enough candidates last time
the
would already be in government thanks
for the call let's go to New Orleans
Joseph in New Orleans
go ahead Joseph how you doing there
George oh good nice to hear yourself
naked we're gonna make a George we don't
know how we're gonna make it because
there are a lot of us afraid here George
we know a lot of people don't want to
say what's going on you know after they
killed Epstein I guess the pan binnacle
is the next move for your new world
daughter that's what we feel here in
America a lot of us are afraid a lot of
us think would be inverted at the
hospitals and we think the Freemasons
the mob in the cartel the female white
with the Freemasons been waiting for
them well when I was a little boy
the Freemasons molested me and when they
molested me a lot of the other kids that
were molested wound up dead the only
reason why I didn't wind up dead is
because my uncle was the Speaker of the
House for the state of Mississippi
I'm Bobby DeLaughter his cousin from the
movie Ghost in Mississippi and my father
who is not a redneck and not a racist
married into that family and my father
was NASA's top scientists Joseph W small
and the third he was NASA's top
scientist and friends all the astronauts
he was John McCain's friends they went
to the Navy together he was team as his
tutor so in the 80s when the crack
cocaine industry the Freemasons in New
Orleans along with the Mafia in cartel
decided they were going to have their
own New World Order and they were going
to push cocaine into every community on
the planet they look at this mantle
every country and I've said it they
don't want to upset your living room
your family life they want to upset
everything cause chaos everywhere
because that's what they are order out
of chaos
but of course yet they have the chaos
first and then they come in and try to
save you with their regalia and
dialectical whatever you want to call it
and I've been watching this over 50
years I lost them as they murdered my
wife and my children in New Orleans in
1993 1993 three cops go into the house
and they killed my wife and kids
they blame a black man for the murder
Dwayne Parker three months later Hillary
Clinton and her husband pushed the brady
bill through the office using that
attack that attack on my wife and kids
well I would be attack my family while
they attack my dad at NASA because my
dad was the investigator on the Space
Shuttle disaster
he knew that somebody had tampered with
the o-rings and he was trying to find
off it is definitely a multi-level
conspiracy I'm afraid to say Joseph they
are does not allow us to thoroughly
investigate all these allegations there
your allegations nor ours but
fascinating and nonetheless let's go
down to Sydney and talk to Michael about
Venezuela go ahead Michael
yeah hi George hi I'm I'd like to pick
up on what you're saying you know about
the Bank of England's feeling
Venezuela's called yeah acting up
nothing less you know that uncommon
through us and England and other Western
powers to steal countries fall I mean
like deliver Rock yeah I invited Iraq
and they looted all the entities and
they stole the ball that the Reserve
Bank they'd assign him to be and
basically the Western world runs around
the world looting and pillaging and then
they had the hard to call losses in you
know in America nobody talking about
looters has never visited the British
Museum yeah yeah and I think that later
on Wall Street and then I thought that
losses on Wall Street which is in London
or the you know corporate leaders always
be protesting violence and oppression
and they never talk about the routine
years the ruling class no no I mean
looting for them is someone putting
their boot through the window of Nike
and making off with some trainers as I
would see Michael there's they're small
thieves and there's big thieves
there's a small pirates and those big
pirates go ahead Michael
yeah I totally agree
George you know arm you know i mean i
don't agree with looting you know
normally not i mean nine but you're the
hall of capitalism's based on lutein
coming in appropriation of work a
surplus value it's looting you know and
like it's legalized looting and Melanie
the question is that and the working
classes being looted all over the world
people are living in poverty wide you
know Jeff Bezos is got one hundred and
fifty billion dollars it's made to have
you know one trillion dollars by 2034 I
mean where does it start wind enough
enough you know Hannity Fitness we could
my life fantastic called what time is it
in the morning there Michael really I'm
following in 5:00 a.m. I take my hat off
to you
thanks very much in not just for
watching and listening but calling in um
no I need you to vote on this Paul is
the Labour Party engaged in a purge yes
eighty-five percent that's up to and be
no 15 percent you've got an hour left in
which to vote on that and there will be
a second Paul so I don't have any more
social media I need to bring me in some
more I see that you're struggling with
it already thanks for that so in the
second hour I'll be talking to dr.
Gerald Horne he's got a new book out but
I love his old book I'm gonna put it
there for you to see it is the book on
Paul Robeson the artist as a
revolutionary it's the best book on Paul
Robeson that I have ever read now Paul
as you know was our very first inductee
into the mother of all talk shows Hall
of Fame
I might squeeze in a question or two
about Paul Robson with my guest dr.
Gerald Horne is the author and the mores
professor of history and
african-american studies at the
University of Houston his new book is
the dawning of the apocalypse the root
of slavery white supremacy settler
colonialism and capitalism in the long
sixteenth century he's a remarkable man
I interviewed them for my Sputnik show
on television last week some of you may
have seen him but we'll get a longer
opportunity to talk to him in the course
of the second hour and after dr. Gerald
will be talking to rob inna Qureshi an
old friend of mine actually from
Scotland on the situation in Glasgow
where three people were murdered and
three others were stabbed including a
police officer who is remains critically
ill though stable in hospital about the
situation the powder keg that was
deliberately created by government
policy amongst refugees and asylum
seekers in the city of Glasgow it's a
scandal that has not yet emerged
properly on the national scene but it is
going to after I've spoken to the
redoubtable Robina in the next hour let
me do a couple of social media Fergus
says what's going to happen when we run
out of food globally
do you trust Bill Gates that's a bit of
a non sequitur
I don't trust Bill Gates to do anything
about us running out of food globally
and neither do I think we're going to
run out of food
globally Gunter says what does Galloway
know about American politics nothing
because he will not acknowledge wall
street runs the economy when did I not
acknowledge that Ghanta sorry you've
lost me Nigel says Galloway is blinkered
that caller from New Orleans is dropped
just voicing what a lot of people have
been looking into for several years now
oh yeah Nigel
our caller from New Orleans said his
father was investigating the
Oh of the Space Shuttle was close to
identifying someone who had tampered
with it he said that the police had bust
into his house and murdered his wife and
children though that was the third item
on his long list of issues that I raised
asked him what the Freemasons had to do
with it all and he didn't answer it he
then dragged in Bill and Hillary Clinton
it seemed to me a compendium of
conspiracy theories if any one of them
had been properly enunciated I would
have allowed the call to continue but
when someone comes on and throws of the
most grave and serious allegations if
true against living unknown people I
have a duty to move the conversation on
otherwise will be prosecuted otherwise
we'll have to pay potentially large sums
of money to people defendant and
slandered here on our platform and I
can't do that
so Nigel are not blinkered in fact it's
the opposite of being blinkered it's
that I can see clearly when something is
worth pursuing of the conversation and
when it isn't and I formed the view that
our caller from New Orleans didn't
require a conversation with me or with
you but with a different sort of
professional altogether now that might
be brutal of me but it's my job to make
that kind of judgment call and I made it
and stand by it here's the news with
Jamie Lowe curious about our curricula
have something to say
then call us now to join the debate on
the mother of all dog shows
with George Galloway tune on every
Tuesday to loud and clear for a regular
segment called false prophets a weekly
look at Wall Street and corporate
capitalism where we talk about the big
economic issues of the week from the
point of view of working people the poor
and the u.s. position in the global
economy join us this Tuesday and every
Tuesday with financial policy analyst
Daniel Sankey right here on radius but
think it's time to double down with Max
and Stacey yeah double down we're
talking markets finance business
economics to change blame just about
everything money related on Sputnik it's
called double down we're asking our dead
cats bouncing or have fundamentals
change that's this week and double down
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
[Music]
radio Sputnik news Russia has strongly
denied reports that it offered to
Taliban and its associated malicious
bounties to kill US troops in
Afghanistan citing US officials the New
York Times Washington Post and Wall
Street Journal reported that a Russian
military intelligence unit offered the
alleged bounties last year the Russian
embassy in the US said the claims have
led to threats to its diplomats the
Taliban also denied doing any deal with
Russian intelligence agencies and u.s.
President Donald Trump also poured cold
water on the reports saying that it was
fake news and tweeting that he never had
a briefing about it
the reports came as the u.s. attempt to
negotiate a peace deal to end the
nineteen year war in Afghanistan the
unnamed officials cited by the New York
Times said US intelligence agencies had
concluded months ago that a unit of
Russia's GRU Military Intelligence
Agency had sought to destabilize its
adversaries by covertly offering
bounties for successful attacks on
coalition forces more than 10 million
people worldwide have been affected with
coronavirus according to latest reports
and more than 500,000 have died a
further 36 people died in the UK after
testing positive for over 19 latest
government biggest show it brings the
total number of recorded deaths in all
settings to 43,000 550 are for the third
day running there were no deaths in
Scotland the US has recorded around 2.5
million cases and at least 125,000
deaths
arise it's been reported in 36 US states
including Florida which some experts of
caution could be the next epicenter for
infections China has imposed a strict
lockdown near Beijing to curb a fresh
outbreak of Cobra to 19 affecting nearly
500,000 people it's believed that the
outbreak started in a food market the
Rolling Stones have warned Donald Trump
that he could face legal action if he
continues using their songs at his
campaign rallies a statement from the
band's legal team said it was working
with performing rights organization vmi
to stop the unauthorized use of their
music the junk campaign used the song
you can't always get what you want at
last week's controversial rally in Tulsa
Oklahoma the same songs also used by the
Trump campaign
during the 2016 US election the same
year that the ban tweeted that the
Rolling Stones do not endorse Donald
Trump earlier this month the family of
rock musician Tom Petty issued a cease
and desist letter to the Trump campaign
over the unauthorized use of his song I
won't back down at the Tulsa rally the
man shot dead by police during a
stabbing attack in Glasgow has been
named as bad red in Abdallah
Adam he was from Sudan the 28 year olds
identity is based on information the
deceased provided to the Home Office
earlier this year police Scotland said
PC David White was one of the six people
injured in the attack get the Park Inn
hotel on Friday two hotel staff were
stabbed as were three residents who are
asylum seekers all are in hospital
police Scotland said it was continuing
to investigate the circumstances
dozens of ethnic minority Labour MPs
have been accused of racism by Britain's
Home Secretary
Priti Patel hit back at a letter from
opposition politicians which claimed
that she used her heritage and
experiences of racism to gasps like the
very real racism faced by black people
and communities across the UK for 32 MPs
who signed it told Patel that being a
person of color does not automatically
make you an authority on all forms of
racism they urged her to reflect on her
words and to consider the impact it had
towards black communities in the UK
trying to highlight their voices against
racism Patel responded they clearly take
the stance and the position that I just
don't conform to their preconceived idea
or stereotypical view of what an ethnic
minority woman should stand for and
represent that in itself she said is
racist
voting has begun in a presidential
election in Poland that is seen as a
measure of support for the country's
right-wing government president Andrzej
Duda a 48 year old conservative backed
by the ruling law and justice party is
running against ten other candidates as
he
aims for a second five-year term and
finally Jamaica's governor-general will
no longer wear a British royal insignia
for personal use that depicts the
Archangel Saint Michael trampling Satan
who is fraught with dark skin Governor
General Patrick Allen the British
monarchies representative in Jamaica
said that he is suspending the use of
the insignia of the Order of Michael
Ernst and George because of its
offensive implications the insignia has
the illustration of some michael and
satan on one of its sites
it shows Satan as a dark-skinned man
under the foot of a white Archangel and
has recently caused anger in Jamaica in
his statement Allen said the suspension
follows his acknowledgment of concerns
raised by citizens over the image on the
medal and the growing global rejection
of the use of objects that normalize
continued degradation of people of color
Allen sent a letter to the Chancellor of
the order of st. Michael and st. George
requesting a revision of the image
recommending that it be changed to
reflect an inclusive image of the shared
humanity of all peoples and that's the
latest here on Sputnik news are you
Jamie Lowe
[Music]
you're listening to radio Sputnik
the untold
welcome to the Open University of the
airwaves with George Galloway fully on
Sputnik radio dr. Gerald Horne is a
Renaissance man a writer and a
communicator of the first rank he is the
professor of history and
african-american studies at the
University of Houston and I spoke to him
a week or so ago about the black lives
matter upsurge and so on but I also took
the opportunity as he is about refer of
the great Paul Robson to talk to him
about the great man I'm hoping to
replace that this evening if I have him
on skype online dr. Gerald thank you
again for joining me not that long has
elapsed since I last spoke to you but
the situation continues to develop and
I'd like to as it were test a couple of
hypotheses on you the movement black
lives matter and we know it's not a
movement that you pay a subscription to
and you get a card and and all of that
but roughly speaking the mass movement
that erupted in the wake of the lynching
of George Floyd has run out of
constructive steam has pulled down the
most offensive of the slaver statues
about the turn to much more
controversial and divisive emblems even
though a case could be made I'm sure for
all of them to pull down marks the
beginning of the end of the current
phase anyway of that movement what do
you think of that hypothesis well I
think it's premature to say and with
regard to the tearing down of statues I
think that this is taking place in the
context of a total rewriting in Reid
visioning of the origins the United
States of America and I'm happy to say
I've been part of that process that is
to say that many are now looking with
the jaundiced eye at the claims made in
1776 by slave owners that somehow they
were in the vanguard of humanity recall
it was your countryman Samuel Johnson
who said at the time that he found it
curious that those who were drivers of
Negroes are always yelping about liberty
and freedom and I think that what has
happened in the United States is that
those who consider themselves to be u.s.
Patriots have oversold the history of
the United States they put forward a
kind of immaculate conception of the
formation of United States a creation
myth and at the same time when you look
at other revolutionary processes they
take a very one-sided view that is to
say they don't have anything positive to
say about the Cuban revolutionary
process they hardly have anything
positive to say about the French
revolutionary process and so I think as
a result that has helped to generate
this backlash understandably against the
so-called revolutionary process that
created the United States of America at
that point and I agree with every one of
it but what would be the message sent by
pulling down the statue of Abraham
Lincoln who who bathed the United States
in blood in a civil war to defeat the
Confederacy and free the slaves
well I'm afraid to say that rethinking
the sainted image of Abraham Lincoln is
also part of this process of revision in
United States history keep in mind as I
have written and other historians have
written that during the course of the
u.s. Civil War mr. Lincoln was
negotiating with Brazil to ship all of
the US Negroes to Brazil after
emancipation in fact that had been the
dominant line of certain numbers of the
u.s. elite emancipation then deportation
then if you look at the statue in
question in Washington DC
it has a very paternalistic
condescending image of a black man at
the feet of mr. Lincoln and that is an
image
many people find to be distasteful and
odious so you'd pull that one down would
you I put it in a museum with proper
context yeah you see I'm looking at it
now is a very condescending look from
Lincoln on the other hand you could say
that the black man is getting off his
knees in that statue that he has been on
his knees because he was a slave and
that thanks to Lincoln he's now getting
up I'm just glancing at it now you know
it better than me but I was one reading
of it isn't it possibly but that's not
the reading of those activists in
Washington DC who finds it offensive and
in any case if you look at the so-called
Emancipation Proclamation of January 1st
1863 it was a war fighting measure it
did not freeze slaves where Lincoln had
power such as in Maryland right across
the line from the District of Columbia
and only freed quote unquote the
enslaved in jurisdictions where he had
no power such as Texas that is to say he
was trying to encourage the black men in
particular to lead the plantations and
join the United States Army so they
could defeat the Confederacy so once
again I think that the United States
elite has overplayed its hand on the one
hand it has denigrated every
revolutionary process on planet Earth
since 1776 on the other hand has tried
to maintain this pristine and pure image
of what's going on in the United States
and that's like trying to write to
horses going in different directions at
the same time it just won't wash and now
they'd have to reap the whirlwind well
there's no doubt that the whole concept
of American exceptionalism is as the
original sin in your country in my view
because of course no sooner had for
whatever reason Lincoln and Grant
defeated the Confederacy they turned
their armies to go west and to complete
the annihilation and expropriation of
the Native Americans whose land it was
in
place you're absolutely correct and even
under the government of mr. Lincoln you
had one of the largest mass executions
in the history of this bloody country
I'm speaking of what happened in the
early 1860s when the indigenous leaders
in what is now Minnesota were executed
in max because they were objecting to
their land being taken and it's
oftentimes said that slavery is the
original sin of the United States of
America I think that's a gross
overstatement the original sin was the
invasion of North America the seizing of
Native American land the liquidation of
the Native American population and then
bringing and slaved Africans across the
Atlantic until we reach that basic
fundamental understanding there will be
no peace in this country how does a
country with two such original sins so
livid on their on their record come to
regard itself as the the policeman the
judge the leader of the world well that
is the $64 question is it not I mean
it's like the thief yelling stop thief
but I'm afraid to say that some of our
friends in the international community
have been a bit too credulous and their
acceptance of these creation myths about
the founding of the United States about
slave owners supposedly leading a fight
for freedom and justice that is not only
taught in the United States of America
I'm afraid to say it's a line that's
taught all over the world and I think
our international friends really should
know better it did I had myself a cause
to visit the United States Senate in
2005 it became quite a celebrity
celebrated the occasion and there I was
confronted by a people who quite clearly
regarded themselves as princes not
senators but princes and it struck me
then that for all this revolutionary and
report
Lacan talked the ruling elite in the
United States really does regard itself
is rather royal I think you are correct
I think it was the Irish Patriot of the
19th century Daniel O'Connell
he said that in 1776 when the rule of
London was overthrown in North America
or at least in the United States what
became the United States that what
happened was the replacement of a
certain kind of aristocracy of lineage
with an aristocracy of race and I'll
leave it to you to determine if that was
a step forward for Humanity certainly
that's the line that's been taught to
generations in this country but for
those on the receiving end of this
poison dart this was no leap for
Humanity this was a great leap backwards
well we're definitely not going to take
you back professor so I discourage any
hopes in that regard you've made your
bed your rulers have and you must lie in
it so how does it look now is Trump
successfully weaponizing the black lives
matter movement and the statues and so
on into his preferred narrative of law
and order and if so how do you think
that's going to break in November well
it's too soon to tell
keep in mind that you really can't take
these polls seriously I remember in
November 2016 looking at the New York
Times website and up until about 15
minutes before the polls closed they had
Hillary Rodham Clinton winning the
election and then you refresh the page
at 9:00 p.m. Eastern and Donald Trump
was declared victorious so now the polls
are telling us that mr. Biden is a hit
by double digits but you have to keep in
mind that many people are embarrassed
and chagrined about admitting their
support for mr. Trump secondly I think
that even our friends on the left the
United States really underestimate the
depth of retrograde opinion and attitude
amongst the bulk I'm afraid to say of
the euro-american working class and
middle class and
then as your comments suggested mr.
Trump is fundamentally turning the
tables on the movement by portraying
himself as the defender of law and order
and many are willing to overlook his
defense of Confederate heroes and
Confederate statues in that regard
now the Russia gate is back the last
three weeks or four weeks of lashing
China as the eternal and global Evo has
been put to one side for a little bit at
least and the liberal media today has
discovered that the Taliban were really
quite nice sorts and all they were
waiting for was the Russians to come
along and give them some rubles at which
point they began trying to shoot
American soldiers now unless you've
never heard of the last centuries of
Afghan resistance to foreign occupation
from Alexander the Great to Donald Trump
the not-so-great you would know that the
Afghans resist all foreign occupations
and always and that the only people who
ever paid Islamist fanatics in
Afghanistan to kill occupiers award were
the United States government themselves
in the 1980s who gave them a king's
ransom in money and material will this
be another successful attack on Trump or
do you think people have grown tired of
unattributable briefings from unnamed
intelligence officers well obviously
it's too soon to say but basically what
you would exposed is the fact that the
Democratic Party when it comes to
foreign policy in some ways is no better
in many ways or worse than the
Republicans what I mean is is that it is
the harebrained idea of
Anita the Democratic Party to confront
Moscow and Beijing simultaneously the
difference with Trump is that they're
willing to make nice with the European
Union I don't think that that's a
winning foreign policy in fact I think
it's a disastrous foreign policy and I'm
happy to hear that you brought up the
1980s because you rarely hear in this
country any reflection on the fact that
it was the United States government in
the 1980s which helped to pump armed
Stinger missiles and all the rest to
these religious zealots in order to
weaken the former Soviet Union they came
to power and by 2001 attacked the World
Trade Center in New York and the
Pentagon in Washington DC Virginia and
apparently we're trying to attack the
White House as well with the plane that
crashed in Pennsylvania so once again I
think that the Democrats are barking up
the wrong tree recalled that Susan Rice
the national security adviser under
President Obama after the gorge floor
protests erupted postmates 25 20/20
suggested that it was actually the hand
of Moscow that was behind the George
Floyd protest which is the looniest idea
since Looney Tunes and should have
discredited her for all time but you
still see her making an appearance
regularly on television which Susan Rice
or Kamala Harris be a step forward for
black people in the United States if
they became the vice presidential pick
well I don't think so and it's
interesting that you mentioned Kamala
Harris of course she is not only of
South Asian ancestry she's of Jamaican
ancestry of course under these peculiar
and unique rules the United States that
means she's defined as a black woman but
I do think that if she is selected as
vice president I don't have more to do
with the other half of our ancestry that
is to say the United States is very much
concerned about recruiting India into
the anti-china bloc and I dare say that
a Biden is elected in November with
Kamala Harris on the ticket she will be
heading to New Delhi by January very
interesting now I haven't read your new
book but I have read your
all book and it is and I've read a lot
of Paul Robson it is the book on Paul
Robson he was the first person inducted
into the Hall of Fame of this show
Paul Robson is number one in the hall of
fame of the mother of all talk shows did
we get that right absolutely as a matter
of fact if there were any justice in
this country Washington DC might be
renamed Robeson city because he was the
tallest tree in our forest he was an
excellent athlete and excellent singer
an excellent football player excellent
actor and a dynamic and dynamite
political activist who was Pro socialist
all the way and it's that latter factor
that led to his being sideline to his
being quote blacklisted unquote in the
United States in the 1950s and with him
dying ignominiously according to the
u.s. elite in 1976 and a modest home in
Philadelphia now how did that happen
professor this man was once this
glittering world historic figure and
yeah I bet that not many people in the
United States or in Britain have ever
heard of him sadly enough it shows you
the power of the propaganda machinery in
the United States of America in
particular once again they can make
people all over the world not least in
this country think a slaveholders revolt
was a great leap forward for liberty and
freedom and I think that that same
propaganda machinery that's besmirched
the excellent reputation of one Paul
Robeson who really needs to be
rehabilitated and I think that that
process is taking place understand that
there is a movie now being made about
his life at least I hope so and
certainly we need to teach the younger
generation about his sterling existence
in his sterling career dr. Gerald Horne
best of luck with your new book and a
pleasure an honor to interview you
tonight on
mother of all talk shows thanks very
much indeed for joining us let me take a
very brief break radio Sputnik
[Music]
tune in every Tuesday - loud and clear
for a regular segment called false
prophets a weekly look at Wall Street
and corporate capitalism where we talk
about the big economic issues of the
week from the point of view of working
people the poor and the u.s. position in
the global economy join us this Tuesday
and every Tuesday with financial policy
analyst Daniel Sankey right here on
radio Sputnik want to talk get in touch
with us at radio at Sputnik news calm we
are talking twenty four hours a day
seven days a week you are listening you
the most essential out of the endless
information space radio Sputnik telling
the untold
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm 24 hours a
day seven days a week we give you the
most essential information out there
radio Sputnik telling the untold George
Galloway and the mother of all talk
shells to join us at the College of
knowledge where there are no tuition
fees for now on my Twitter page is the
Labour Party engaged in a purge a yes B
no you've got half an hour or so to do
so now this is where I turn history
teacher and look back at the events over
the momenta seven days that shaped our
world for good or ill this was the day
in 1914 that the First World War was set
in training when Franz Ferdinand
Archduke of Austria and his wife Sophie
were assassinated in Sarajevo by young
Serb nationalists Gavrilo Princip at
10:45 a.m. five years later to the day
in the Hall of Mirrors are not setting
in the Palace of Versailles in France
the treaty was signed ending the war
when Germany was forced to concede on
all points the League of Nations was
established but the US Congress
neither ratified the Treaty of
Versailles nor joined the League of
Nations in 2004 having invaded the Iraq
and held power for fifteen months the
United States handed power back to the
Iraqi people at a low-key ceremony in
Baghdad
Lukie you might say it deservedly was us
administrator Paul Bremer remember him
transferred sovereignty to an Iraqi
judge at a handover brought forward two
days in an attempt to prevent the
occasion being marked by bloodshed and
wonder what happened
Bremer flew out of the country shortly
thereafter on the 29th of June 1966 the
US began the inexorable escalation and
ultimately futile pursuit of victory in
the American war on Vietnam when US
planes
and the North Vietnamese capital Hanoi
and the port city of Haiphong for the
first time in 1974 Maria
Estella Isabel Martinez de perón a
former cabaret dancer was sworn in as an
interim leader of the Argentine Republic
she was out in Tina's first female
president and 43 became the youngest
latin-american head of state is about
perón's presidency lasted until 1976 or
two years when she was deposed by a
military junta led by Jorge Rafael
Videla don't cry for me Argentina
followed some years later on the 30th of
June 1905 the battleship potemkin
arrived at Odessa were sailors took the
bodies of dead crewmen ashore the crew
had mutinied and sailors joined the
civilians in revolutionary actions of
the 1905 revolution which was of course
the precursor of the successful one in
1917 on July 1st in 1963 kim Philby was
revealed as the third man in the
so-called cambridge spy ring the others
were British diplomats guy Burgess and
Donald MacLean who had also been
recruited by the Soviet Union I'm
reading a wonderful book at the moment
on George Blake who was another KGB
agent well ensconced in British
intelligence who turns out to have been
a much more significant agent for the
Soviet Union than I had thought at the
time he was rescued from Wormwood Scrubs
by a rope ladder thrown over the wall
I'm not making this up and he escaped in
in a camper van all the way back to
Moscow where he is still alive to this
day George Blake I tell you if I'd met
him but then I'd have to kill you on the
same day in 1967 The Beatles
album sergeant pepper's Lonely Hearts
Club Band went to number one in the
United States and stayed there for 15
weeks younger viewers and listeners
won't know what any of that means an
album number 1 in the charts the chart
still exists and in 1997 Hong Kong was
handed back to the Chinese authorities
ending more than 150 years of British
control the British flag was lowered
over government house home to the last
Governor Chris Patten known as fat pang
at midnight well known as fat pang an
admirable name for him
in January sorry in July 2nd 1964 the
civil rights bill one of the most
important pieces of legislation in
American history became law the united
states president lyndon b johnson signed
the bill creating equal rights in
boating education public accommodation
union membership and in federally
assisted programs regardless of race
color religion or national origin it may
actually be implemented one day i
watched her with my oldest son this week
Mississippi Burning with the
incomparable Gene Hackman I had a lot of
difficulty finding it for some reason
both Skye and Netflix have taken off
their roster of movies and one side
rewatched her in my case and he'd
watched it for the first time and in the
current conditions that exists in the
United States are well understood of why
they had withdrawn it if you ever want
to feel boiling with anger and rage
then watch Mississippi Burning and watch
Gene Hackman in the barbershop in 2005
the world's biggest music stars
performed at the Live Aid concerts
around the globe / aimed at persuading
political leaders to tackle poverty in
Africa that might happen one day two
concerts in ten cities including London
Philadelphia Paris Berlin Johannesburg
Rome and Moscow played to hundreds of
thousands of people a TV audience of
several hundred million watched the gigs
ahead of the g8 summit of leaders on
global poverty and climate change on
July 3rd in 1928 John Logie Baird a
Scotsman demonstrated the first color
television transmission in London and in
the same city in 1966 at least 31 people
were arrested after their protest
against the American war on Vietnam
turned violent police moved in after
scuffles broke out at the demonstration
by more than 4000 people outside the US
Embassy in Grosvenor Square and in 1971
the door singer Jim Morrison was found
dead in a bath in an apartment in Paris
he had died of a heart attack aged just
27 Morrison is buried at Pere Lachaise
Cemetery in Paris where his grave has
become a shrine for successive
generations of fans and I myself have
visited it Edith Piaf is buried very
close by as are the graves of the Paris
Commune ants who were executed against
the wall of the cemetery and in 1988 the
American naval warship Vincennes
patrolling the Persian Gulf shot down
and the Iranian passenger jet after
apparently mistaking it for an f-14
fighter as you do all those on board the
airline are almost 300 people were
killed
Iran has never accepted that it was an
accident and July the 4th was of course
the day in 1776 that the US Congress
proclaimed the declaration of
independence from Britain had the
founding fathers foreseen who the 45th
President was to become they might have
had second thoughts
just another seven days in our glorious
often in glorious history that was the
week that was is the Labour Party
engaged in a porch a yes it is six
percent no fourteen percent down one you
can vote until you've got an hour ten
minutes
I think - bull let's go to the first
caller Tim in Glasgow Tim welcome hello
Josh thanks very much guys we want
weapon Raiden but you've still got the
accent that's what counts
yeah definitely man our applause book
but not blog the man definitely their
jobs definitely just what you mentioned
a bit incident at the park in hotel
yesterday and the terribly inaccurate
reporting the BBC in sky I mean it was
absolutely short him at one point the
BBC reported three people dead including
their and assailant and it is somebody
nothing like it or not well I myself
have fallen victim to it Tim and you
might well you might well say I should
know better
I believe did the BBC and sky that three
people had died and I said so not half
an hour ago but it turns out the only
dead person was the madman with the big
knife was great but also I mean it was
causing the great when to jump and his
usual would both feet whether an you
know rabble-rousing
mister for asked for one name in illegal
immigrants well you forgot I remember
that these guys mean so chaotic why so
they get thirty five times a week
Social Security right and that's taken
away from the mess hotel so they after
what to the hotel food the hotel mania
okay is the most Arvind up but there's
no independents in there whatsoever and
it's not easy weather with no money at
all you know and a foreign country now
I'm going to be talking to a woman who
knows Robina Qureshi in just about 20
minutes maybe Tim on a very subject but
the fact that these people were all
hooked up in the hotel which coronavirus
accident waiting to happen
a major a mental health crisis waiting
to happen when they were given an hour
to get out of the flats that they were
in and living independently in in order
to be shunted into these hotels for the
profit of a private company exactly yes
and also they had torment at a rate Wang
Martin doing the street last week
laughter it was Detroit's way of
demonstration the protectin statues
Martin doing this thing in blue Catania
and yeah guys gonna I mean it's really
you know that's a glass region myself be
coming from the way you say the way you
see it's absolutely intolerable you know
and fast moving you know for them this
sensational well that's a chaser
reporting a Faust just just really a
detour even know when that was withdrawn
because I was blissfully unaware that
actually none of the people stabbed by
this individual had actually died I was
I was absolutely sure there were three
dead but I never saw that news withdrawn
now is there now on the screen look
three dead and stabbing in sterilizable
that's absolutely disgraceful I mean
it's supposed to be the BBC in the sky
you know a ten year broadcast but yeah
you know the report no it's an absolute
disgrace George ten thanks for the call
Glen is in Carlisle
go ahead Glen hi George pleasure to
speak to you again I wanted to talk to
you a couple of things that what hon - I
wanted to talk to you about how we have
both the first is similar to what Jim
was actually also talking about the
issue of the British media and indeed
there the media across the Western world
and the way in which that relates to
democracy and
I'm of the firm belief I have been from
some time out that because of the way
our media is controlled because of the
way it is a mouthpiece for the
government were under the neoliberal
capitalist governments we've been under
for decade after decade after decade the
in essence as a result of that we don't
really live in what could technically or
really in any tangible way be construed
as a democracy because I'm certainly not
oh yeah it's certainly not free because
a country which has a lie machine as its
Fourth Estate is clearly not able to
properly function as a democracy because
it is a democracy based on a false
pretenses hmm no exactly and that that's
what I was then just getting to if
people are being told what to think and
if people are constantly as victim or
constantly have that their judgment
their view of reality their perception
of everyone's going on distorted and
mislead by as you actually put it this
lie machine look how it worked in the in
the December election blend all the news
machine which marched the people into
the column of Boris Johnson have now
decided that Boris Johnson is the worst
thing that's ever happened to this
country yeah all these commentators on
the BBC on sky in The Guardian in The
Times in the independent all these
papers that have turned against Boris
Johnson are the very people who
destroyed Jeremy Corbyn and yes made the
Boris Johnson government unavoidable
ineluctable know you like it and then
let the two later has been completely to
baseman's than just spinning whatever
they can whatever they want to on a win
- that is far
their need satisfy their interest which
often are shared with the interest of
the purple shed with the interest of the
I was in government in their interest
overlap considerably well they will
spend whatever suits their interest
suits their desires and benefit with
them and that's what they've always done
and I'd like to say it's not a democracy
when people are told what to think as
they were in Hitler's Germany as they
were in Harry he does Japan and we're
told what the things yeah luckily there
are lacunae like this one where we try
to break out of the prevailing orthodoxy
Glenn thanks very much for that call in
40 seconds
it's Robina Qureshi on the stabbings in
Glasgow don't miss that radio Sputnik
tune in every Wednesday - loud and clear
with Brian Becker and John Kiriakou for
a regular segment called beyond nuclear
where Brian and John discussed nuclear
issues including weapons energy waste in
the future of nuclear technology in the
United States with Kevin Kamps the
radioactive waste watchdog and the
organization beyond nuclear listen on
Wednesdays right here on radio slepping
[Music]
[Applause]
want to talk get in touch with us at
radio at Sputnik news calm
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
tune in every Thursday - loud and clear
with Brian Becker for the regular
segment called veterans for peace where
we focus on the contemporary issues of
war and peace that affect veterans their
families the country and the world as a
whole
veterans for peace president Gerry
Condon joins the show every Thursday
hear about this and more every Thursday
right here on radio Sputnik we are above
all the latest developments and we don't
take any sides radio Sputnik telling the
untold
the mother of all talk shows with George
Galloway the world is our classroom and
you're welcome to sit in and join the
seminar now the polls about to close
this the Labour Party engaged in a purge
a yes 86% be know 14% you can still vote
on my Twitter feed at George Galloway
Lubner says on Twitter
is it safe to conclude the both the Tory
and the Labour Party aren't serving UK
citizens I'd say so Luna Wilde rain says
Kier tackling what he deems
anti-semitism is his top priority
rlb retweeted an article containing a
fact I despair for freedom of speech
regarding Israel despair for
Palestinians God helped the remaining
Labour Party members who speak out on
the issue silenced the plan all along
the only thing wrong with that wild rain
is that Rebecca long Bailey supported
the porch of other people guilty of
stating only facts the most high-profile
of whom was Ken Livingstone but there
were many others Jackie Walker for one
mark Wordsworth for another and perhaps
most celebrated was the last of the
carbon supporting MPs Chris Williamson
he too was stating a fact and he was
purged and Rebecca long Billy supported
the purging of him and all of the
preceding and now she's been purged you
see as I tried to tell people all along
you can't feed the crocodile and think
that it's not going a venture to eat you
you can't defang a tiger claw by claw it
doesn't work you'll end up in its belly
- no Robin akashi's are a doubt about a
campaigner
for Refugees for asylum seekers for the
be AME community she's a human rights
campaigner but most importantly in this
story is the director of positive action
in housing and she was the foremost
advocate against the policy of suddenly
moving all of glass goals asylum seekers
out of the flats that they were living
in flats that no one else wanted to live
in and putting them all in hotels like
the Park Hotel in Glasgow which turned
into a bloodbath over the last 48 hours
or so to hear more about how that
happened and what exactly happened we've
managed to get Robina Qureshi on the
shore and I'm very glad that she could
join us Rubina thank you for that have I
got that right
that the people that are now living in
these hotels were once upon a time or
living independent lives whilst awaiting
the adjudication of their cases but were
bundled out of those independent flats
and put into these hotels well that was
a coronavirus waiting to happen but it
was also a mental-health crisis waiting
to happen wasn't it yes George
and there were 370 asylum seekers who
were living in serviced accommodation
new to the country but living perhaps
for a few months and serviced
accommodation that was their home so it
could cook they could keep an
environment clean they had some control
and privacy over their own lives and all
of a sudden in march towards the end of
march in the at the start of the long
term when the streets were empty and
when hotels were emptied because they
were a coronavirus risk and people were
operated by the Mears group at the end
of March beginning of April and given
half an hour's notice and taken four or
five to a van
and docked in hotels all over Glasgow
basically treating a public health
disaster as well Wheatly to happen by
having hotel clusters or our potential
outbreaks and fires all over a glasgow
city bland school and you have to
remember the context in the context is a
lockdown or pandemic and people
basically the city had neither mich Mich
shift hospital at their sec see which
you'll be aware of for a thousand new
patients from corner virus and has built
a mortally at ellington to prepare for a
hundreds of dead as well that was a
context within which the asylum seekers
were uprooted from all different
countries Afghanistan Syria and Cameroon
somebody came in lots of different
countries and they were basically are
routed without any assistance whatsoever
and left on the hood to languish they
had their 5.39 pence a deed that they
received as an allowance from the Home
Office removed by the nearest group and
then they were unable to spend and
aren't able to spend any money
whatsoever on things like mobile phone
talk hops were unable to buy bottles of
water or some fruit when it was Ramadan
and people were talking about starving
and the calls that we were getting was
from people saying that they had
suicidal thoughts who are desperate to
get out and they are still desperate to
get out and they're saying that please
we need food we just need ferns we need
food and we need a mobile phone tops
because you can't buy a mobile phone
top-ups you can't access lawyers we
can't cut the Wi-Fi so pure we can't
call our families back home at all we
need access to these things and so that
five pounds was the difference between
being just about surviving and what
we're seeing just known which is a
complete mental health crisis you have
to remember six weeks ago a suicidal
Syrian refugee whose family we now
represent
died in the nucleus hotel in Glasgow and
he'd be docked there by me years before
he had been
serviced accommodation in our house it
was a home to him you could cook his own
food he had privacy he was able to clean
his own environment and the hotels
there's no social distancing the lifts
are crowded and the dining areas also
retracted and there was no proper
cleaning of public areas as well so
that's it that's a and that the context
who are what are the Mears group the
news group if you look up corporate
watch actually will tell you exactly who
Mears group visits are multi-billion
outsourcing service company and that has
a major contract with the the UK
government and they took on our billion
pound contract for asylum hers in
Scotland but also in England as well and
so they've got a major contract but this
is no under Mears watch two people have
now died six have been injured including
a police officer this is just in the
last six weeks so God knows what's going
to happen next and because you're
talking about people who are already
fled war and persecution possibly were
tortured possibly a feast and torture on
their journey of seeking asylum to get
to Europe or to the UK and that's what
we're talking about John so they
obviously had government permission to
turn all these people out of the flats
they were living in and called in a
hotel which government the Scottish
government or the Westminster Government
episode UK government that decided the
Home Office decided and that Mears was
too and other Asylum landlord but
particularly Mears we took over from
Scirocco
was to take people out of serviced
accommodation and moved them into hotels
you have to remember there's no market
for hotel accommodation so therefore
these hotels were lying empty and
basically were cheap alternatives to
leaving people in their own homes and
which is what happened I know two people
have died both of whom had complained
about mental health issues and the
Sirian gentleman was and had said that
he had suicidal thoughts that he had
attempted
to kill himself the Home Office was
aware that he'd been in hospital having
attempted suicide just a few days before
he killed himself
so her statement five days before him
was that he'd attempted to kill himself
his mother was seriously ill in Syria he
needed to send money back and the family
in Syria could not understand why he in
the West was unable to send money back
they don't have an understanding that
people are being left absolutely
destitute and homeless and in the UK
they can't comprehend it in fact at that
stage even his family in Syria had good
and he didn't have access to just just
peace of mind being able to clean being
able to access to water be able to
access have access to food and have
access to the right to work none of
these things were open or eye open to
the refugees now know what happened at
the hotel in question what can you tell
us about the state of mind of the of the
would be attempted madara where is that
he had been pleading for help because of
his mental health he had said that you
could take no more that he was exhausted
our understanding is as I was pleading
to be retired to Sudan because he could
take no more in the hotel because the
the food they were feeding them was
monotonous DND I it was given a set
times he was talking about being very
hungry and he was saying that if he had
to get out he'd been left 20 days on his
own in isolation in the hotel with a
brick wall for a view is what we've been
told and that was because he was
suspected of having covered 19 symptoms
and by the end of her or in the middle
of it whatever and he was seeing that
you could take no more and he he wanted
to hit somebody and 11 o'clock the night
before our understanding is is that
other asylum seekers have told us that
they went downstairs to the receptionist
said that this man has severe mental
health problems he needs help somebody
needs to speak to them speak to them
they didn't and I that was 11 o'clock
the night before I understand the next
thing that his lawyer spoke to him and
then a few minutes later the attack took
place and one police officer and six
people were injured including
unaccompanied to say I'm seeking
children
you have to remember the people and they
are very vulnerable they do have mental
health problems they are vulnerable
people and mirrors is not dealing with
as a big company a multinational company
it's not dealing with Asylum hours and
parcels you're dealing with human beings
who are vulnerable and therefore you
have to deal with them and I sense the
manner not operate them on mass of their
homes and document hotels and tell them
to stay there 24/7 in their rooms the
rooms are not cleaned every day the the
Habu access to water that was another
thing that people were seeing the other
thing is is that they were they had a
problem breathing that the the problem
was that they windows don't open
and especially coronavirus and dual
issue of dirty air conditioning which
can transmit viruses people were
terrified of breathing and being in a
room 24/7 being told you're only allowed
to work for half an hour for a walk and
then have to either get not seeing food
at least eight hours and then return to
your room be on your own no contact
charities or fifth groups or lawyers or
anything because there's a lot of time
going on and what you have is a
situation which is basically a tendril
opportunity just to be let and very very
vulnerable people so to be honest I
wasn't surprised when I heard what had
happened and we knew that people were
that the numbers of people seemed that
they were depressed or at risk for
suicide or had suicidal thoughts had
rocketed and the reports to us because
we help people not just with their
housing and not just with their case for
a queenly cookies work we also help them
with crisis grants and when meiosis not
the crisis grants that the nurses doctor
five points there tonight I D we were
giving out thousands of pounds in crisis
grants to asylum seekers and the biggest
priority trip for us was the hotel
asylum seekers which is why the see they
were effectively being it was
effectively hotel detention that was not
a hotel in degree that you are a might
understand it well it was a disaster
waiting to happen and a disaster Julie
took place what should happen next and
what do you think will happen next
and we want to know about the
decision-making about who decided and
why they decided to take people and
operable people of their homes and to
hotels
we want to know why and we want to have
a complete investigation an independent
inquiry into what happened here at
regards I'd 9lb the Syrian refugee who
died the suicidal Syrian refugee and an
investigation - what happened here why
were people operated during a pandemic
it's so cynical actually the statements
that they gave this Authority Poseidon
vachetta they said that the last time as
well six weeks ago what's gonna happen
next who's gonna die next and under
their watch - - refugees of Dimes never
happened before they said to me what lot
people like the we Sara would refer to
instead well no they didn't lot people I
do we ser interpret souls that they did
much worse because are a danger to
public health and the uprooted
vulnerable people from their homes into
hotels
creating further potential out priests
and this this man who is the alleged
attacker apparently was actually
isolating from for suspected their core
419 symptoms and Meerut percent that him
that that the they took the money away
so that people wouldn't catch the virus
from the coins well there was no
government guidance that said stop using
cash you know and yet there was
government guide this thing stay in your
homes do not move thought to any house
moves don't buy or sell houses don't do
any moves landlords can't evict you and
they operated effectively evicted 370
people in the city of Glasgow creating a
major health disaster waiting to happen
even as we speak because now we knew on
the record that the the anecdotal
evidence tells us that that man that the
alleged attacker was isolating due to
cope with 19 symptoms but Mears has said
that there was nobody isolating and that
they had made sure there was nobody able
to isolate such as a cynicism that they
are treated with at this moment that
mirrors in the home office is treated
with that a group of Scottish MPs
refused to meet them on Friday saying
that they could not meet with mirrors
because of trust issues this is before
the attack took place in Freddy wow what
a story
Robina Qureshi thank you indeed nice to
see you again after so long and that
you're still fighting comes as no
surprise
that's why I find your beautiful
children as well thank you who Raveena
thank you another one along in a minute
Robin ah Qureshi human rights campaigner
and director of positive action in
housing let's get the news with Jamie
Lowe curious about our curricula have
something to say then call us now to
join the debate on the mother of all
talk shows with George Galloway tune in
every Tuesday to loud and clear for a
regular segment called false prophets a
weekly look at Wall Street and corporate
capitalism where we talk about the big
economic issues of the week from the
point of view of working people the poor
and the u.s. position in the global
economy join us this Tuesday and every
Tuesday with financial policy analyst
Daniel Sankey right here on radio
Sputnik it's time to double down with
Max and Stacy yeah double down we're
talking markets finance business
economics could change bling just about
everything money related on Sputnik it's
called double down we're asking our dead
cats bouncing or have fundamentals
change that's this week and double down
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm
[Music]
radio Sputnik news Russia has strongly
denied reports that it offered to
Taliban and its associated militias
bounties to kill US troops in
Afghanistan citing US officials the New
York Times Washington Post and Wall
Street Journal reported that a Russian
military intelligence unit offered the
alleged bounties last year the Russian
embassy in the u.s. said the claims have
led to threats to its diplomats the
Taliban also denied doing any deal with
Russian intelligence agencies and u.s.
President Donald Trump also poured cold
water on the reports saying that it was
fake news and tweeting that he never had
a briefing about it the reports came as
the u.s. attempt to negotiate a peace
deal to end the nineteen year war in
Afghanistan the unnamed officials cited
by the New York Times said US
intelligence agencies had concluded
months ago that a unit of Russia's GRU
military intelligence agency had sought
to destabilize its adversaries by
covertly offering bounties for
successful attacks on coalition forces
more than ten million people worldwide
have been affected with coronavirus
according to latest reports and more
than 500,000 have died
a further 36 people died in the UK after
testing positive for Cobras 19 latest
government biggest show it brings the
total number of recorded deaths in all
settings to 43,000 550 for the third day
running there were no deaths in Scotland
the US has recorded around 2.5 million
cases and at least 125,000 deaths
arise it's been reported in 36 US states
including Florida which some experts of
caution could be the next epicenter for
infections China has imposed a strict
lockdown near Beijing to curb a fresh
outbreak of covert 19 affecting nearly
500,000 people it's believed that the
outbreak started in a food market the
Rolling Stones have warned Donald Trump
that he could face legal action if he
continues using their songs at his
campaign rallies a statement from the
band's legal team said it was working
with performing rights organization vmi
to stop the unauthorized use of their
music the junk campaign used the song
you can't always get what you want at
last week's controversial rally in Tulsa
Oklahoma the same songs also
used by the Trump campaign during the
2016 US election the same year that the
BAM tweeted that the Rolling Stones do
not endorse Donald Trump earlier this
month the family of rock musician Tom
Petty issued a cease and desist letter
to the Trump campaign over the
unauthorized use of his song I won't
back down at the Tulsa rally the man
shot dead by police during a stabbing
attacking Glasgow has been named as bad
read in Abdallah Adam he was from Sudan
the 28 year olds identity is based on
information the deceased provided to the
Home Office earlier this year police
Scotland said PC David White was one of
the six people injured in the attack at
the park in hotel on Friday two hotel
staff were stabbed as were three
residents who are asylum seekers all are
in hospital police Scotland said it was
continuing to investigate the
circumstances
dozens of ethnic minority Labour MPs
have been accused of racism by Britain's
Home Secretary
Priti Patel hit back at a letter from
opposition politicians which claimed
that she used her heritage and
experiences of racism to Gaslight the
very real racism faced by black people
and communities across the UK the 32 MPs
who signed it told Patel that being a
person of color does not automatically
make you an authority on all forms of
racism they urged her to reflect on her
words and to consider the impact it had
towards black communities in the UK
trying to highlight their voices against
racism Patel responded they clearly take
the stance and the position that I just
don't conform to their preconceived idea
or stereotypical view of what an ethnic
minority woman should stand for and
represent that in itself she said it's
racist voting has begun in a
presidential election in Poland that has
seen as a measure of support for the
country's right-wing government
president Andrzej Duda a 48 year old
conservative backed by the ruling law
and justice party is running against ten
other candidates as he aims for a second
five-year term and finally Jamaica's
Governor General will no longer wear a
British royal insignia for personal use
that depicts the Archangel Saint Michael
trampling Satan who is fraud with dark
skin
Governor General Patrick Allen the
British monarchies representative in
Jamaica said that he is suspending the
use of
Signia of the order of michael and since
George because of its offensive
implications the insignia has the
illustration of Sir Michael and Satan on
one of its sites
it shows Satan as a dark-skinned man
under the foot of a white Archangel and
has recently caught anger in Jamaica in
his statement Allen said the suspension
follows his acknowledgment of concerns
raised by citizens over the image on the
medal and the growing global rejection
of the use of objects that normalize
continued degradation of people of color
Allen sent a letter to the Chancellor of
the order of Sir Michael and st. George
requesting a revision of the image
recommending that it be changed to
reflect an inclusive image of the shared
humanity of all peoples and that's the
latest here on Sputnik news hi Jamie low
[Music]
you're listening to radio Sputnik
the untold
welcome to the Open University of the
airwaves with George Galloway only on
Sputnik radio okay here's poll number
two would trump supporters peacefully
accept defeat at the polls a yes B no
who know where my money is
social comments Twitter lewdness I've
done that one Justin your poll results
suggest that fifteen percent of your
listeners are trolls and another user
says great show as per I'm just smirking
at the caller from New Orleans see no
evil monkey and Time Bandit says people
are sad they are getting angry statues
and medals my goodness kids are still
starving in the world and they want to
break things Todd says personally I
couldn't care less about statues but
then I'm not hyper sensitive they're
often a good reminder of how things were
and should not be in the future and
Peter says Kirsten Murr is not the whole
Labour Party front bench for the moment
maybe he moved against rlb to divert
attention from the movement in the Labor
Party and in society at large in support
of Palestinians and against Israel's
annexation of Palestinian lands that
they have been occupying for 60 years
please don't follow the rest of the
media in this diversionary tactic when
discussing Palestinian rights Leon says
brilliant from Professor Gerald Horne
what a guy that statue is odious you're
in a hole so stop digging George that's
my job my friend keep digging
John says after the slaves were freed
they were made economic slaves and their
battle is ongoing and Nikki says why are
we looking backwards and on YouTube
Johan says horn play stick correct the
statue should be in a museum with proper
context it is part of history untold and
Tom says
great history lesson from the professor
and George and syndicate says the West
always preaching to everyone about the
rule of law
all the while violating and ignoring
every possible opportunity the West has
gone completely rogue yes we have the
rules-based order lads and on twitter
Georgie says the Labour Party is a toxic
brand unfit for purpose got to start
driving home but I'll listen all the way
and in response to the poll lolli says
the last 40 years have been a purge
Kinnick in the 1980s purging militant it
seems history is repeating itself again
now dr. Ranjit brah is the moats medic
and he joins me now this decisive maybe
turning point and maybe not in a good
way doctor we are about to see all kinds
of things reopen tomorrow the roads are
very much busy are as I can testify this
evening the congregations or people are
simply anonymous I mean they're there
mind boggling some of the scenes from
the beaches from the parks and so on
it's hard to believe this is not all
trouble that's going to come right down
the pipe at us George thanks again for
having me back with you I I concur with
those statements George we've seen in
the world there have been ten point two
million cases and confirmed by testing
and half a million deaths in the UK
we've had three hundred eleven thousand
confirmed cases by testing and as we've
said before perhaps seven percent of the
population only have been affected and
we know that's forty three and a half
thousand confirmed deaths across all
settings according to official
statistics but by excess mortality well
in excess of sixty five thousand that we
don't have precise figures day by day
sometimes we see quite low figures for
the number of infections but looking
week on week really it's remaining very
static George
coog the European director of the World
Health Organization has warned this week
of increasing outbreaks across many
countries and settings including Sweden
Spain Germans we discussed last week
which has an increase in its our rate up
to 2.8 and that was just associated with
a few local outbreaks what we're still
not doing well in this country is
testing and tracing and as a result of
that really we're seeing a static number
of of deaths currently and as you say
lifting of the lockdown implies that in
after the the usual observed lag of two
to three weeks
we're very likely to see significantly
increased numbers again middle you know
if you just look at this week we've had
close to thousand deaths and that's
likely to go up because there as we know
they they registered late and the
numbers are always revised upwards so
really we're not seeing decreasing
numbers and if you look at that the the
rate of infection is around static in
most areas of the country so it's a
problem at the moment that simply isn't
going away George now you and I said
from the beginning that there was
absolutely no certainty that this virus
even originated in China and moreover
and I said it many times that there was
more than one kind of corona virus in
circulation even in the United States
the virus on the west coast was very
different from the virus on the East
Coast and now we discover having earlier
discovered that in Italy there were
cases last year we now discover that at
the beginning of last year in water
which has just been tested in Barcelona
we discover the corona virus so it could
very well be that those of 1920 variant
wasn't a Spanish flu but has entered
history as a Spanish flu that this one
which is now entered history as a
Chinese flu
my actually have come from Spain it
there are several candidates for where
the viruses come from Georgia you're
quite right in fact in October or
November last year there have been cases
of people in France who came down with a
very similar at that point undiagnosable
respiratory infection wasn't able to be
diagnosed the gentleman in question was
a german moroccan origin in paris he
survived that that infection and but but
samples of his aspirant were kept and
subsequently tested once that test for
covett 19 existed and shown that he in
fact did have coverage so there with
there are several documented cases in
France in Spain and probably in the
United States that that data is unclear
of patients who have had copied 19 that
predated the outbreak which was thought
to be initially the origin in wuhan and
and that's not widely appreciated but
there were people at the time that there
were Chinese scientists at the time you
made it quite clear in the face of what
was quite provocative and hostile
propaganda from the United States in
particular that they said and to quote
their words although this virus was
discovered here it doesn't mean it's
originated here and that's kind of
logically unassailable and it was even
the Chinese foreign ministry after
insisting that you know they were doing
their best to combat it and
international solidarity was the order
of the day that we needed to learn from
exactly each others are examples share
technology and share information to help
us combat it the assigning blame was not
helpful that's clearly been the name of
the game for Britain and the United
States in particular but that's part of
their broader global strategy and I said
nothing also ever to do with this viral
outbreak quite so but that would mean
that though the search for patient zero
in China is barking up the wrong tree
because this may have passed from the
animal kingdom to humans all over the
world and much longer ago than the end
of last year
the time line still not clear I think
that the Chinese themselves are
persistent calls again from particularly
from Trump and from the United States
administration prior to the last
Congress of the World Health
Organization that there should be some
kind of international investigation they
mentioned at that time that they were
looking for reparations from China in
the order of a trillion believe it or
not a trillion dollars and they Trump
even mentioned in several interviews the
possibility of canceling China's a stake
in America's national debt which runs
the 1.2 trillion dollars so failing that
they talked about punitive sanctions and
other trade escalating their trade war
so China undercut that entire narrative
by actually calling itself and Zi
Jinping called for an international
investigation but insisted that it must
be an impartial objective investigation
led by the science led by the scientists
and not directed as the United States is
very fond of having investigations that
it directs with and then the science of
course has to follow its preconceived
ideas and conclusions in order to meet
its political ends and I think that
would serve certainly no one's interests
other than a very small elite of very
wealthy people business people within
the US establishment is certainly not in
the interests of workers in Britain or
elsewhere Dr Ng
thank you very much indeed as always for
joining us on the mother of all talk
shows our very own moats medic dr.
Ranjit bra would trump supporters
peacefully accept defeat at the polls a
yes
38% be no 62% very interesting you've
got till 10 o'clock to vote on my
Twitter feed on that poll Chris in
Guildford is on the line on the
coronavirus go ahead Chris good evening
mr. George Galloway how you doing this
how you doing today by the grace of God
I'm fighting fit thank you
see how I am okay okay yeah well anyway
what I was sweet I've been looking at
all these
riots blacklivesmatter over in the UK
and in the US of A now all of a sudden I
don't know if I'm touching things right
or if I'm seeing things right but the
beaches were filed during the week for
the lovely weather we had and all of a
sudden I'm not a new infection rates or
nothing's going up nobody's not dying
I'm wondering if this thing is a hoax
all of a sudden oh well the I don't know
what you would call it the the lag
between catching the virus and
presenting with it is two to three weeks
so we'll need to look at that in in a
week or so we should start to see if
these huge gatherings of people block
parties riots demonstrations and
jamberries to the beach have made any
impact on Britain's figures of people
presenting with the illness my money is
one that it will watch yours on my
money's on people getting infected again
and we're back into lockdown again
that's where my money is
yeah well not have any money left Chris
at this rate thanks very much for your
call my friend Mike is in the Bahamas
like to hear from him go ahead Mike hi
how are you good nice a guy called from
the Bahamas I just heard a question now
we're here in the Bahamas we have not
had a new case of covert 19 since June
14th and I'm just wondering how we seem
to get it under control and that the UK
in the u.s. can't well you're a variable
with respect to the Bahamas you're a
very small population aren't you yes but
we have Sharon coming in too and it must
be coming in because we'd starve we
don't grow anything are you still good
ships cruise ships AB and we still get
flights okay people coming in on holiday
not so much better stick it you have to
self quarantine for two weeks that's
what I was sorry I don't think you would
get that was my next question so people
go out the Bahamas for holidays or to
count down money don't they
well okay you get this thing that it's a
billionaires playground but most of it
isn't and the infrastructure here is is
not that great so this one what's your
theory Mike I just don't see that the UK
and the US are really trying you don't
see why they can't get a handle on it if
if they if a small country like us of
which I mean you think of the Bahamas as
a billionaires playground but it's
actually a rather poor country for the
the mass of the people I have no doubt
about that Mike thanks for the call I've
got to go to Sacramento a lovely lovely
place
I spoke there once John is on the line
there go ahead John yes George I'm just
calling about first of all a longtime
listener just loved the show
thanks I'm calling about the security
theater I'm not a gun person I'm a
really progressive person and me and my
brother did a euro trip over there in
Europe from London to burst Barcelona
and France and Germany and I've never
seen an ar-15 in our life and we've been
all through California I'm an attorney
here in Sacramento and I'm also licensed
in DC we've never seen an ar-15 in our
life so I mean well we have a lot of
security theater here we don't really
experience the same situation you guys
experienced over there and my question
was just whether you think it's as big
of a problem there's as I think it is
because you know being someone that's
never seen in the air 15 it makes me
uncomfortable when I see guns so of
course in Britain the police don't carry
guns nor even pistols it's only
specialised on response officers who
have them in their car or people at the
Moose Airport honorable answers like
airports yeah like in an airport train
station the police in the in the streets
don't carry weapons how long that will
last I'm not sure but in Europe is
absolutely routine the all police motion
I think this town is down well I don't
know if I was a police officer and I
knew there were a lot of terrorists and
serious criminals out there that did
have weapons I don't think I'd let them
take my weapon away yeah I guess so
maybe maybe that's just me I mean did
you could we keep them in their cop cars
and you see them if you glance in there
but you know we try to keep it low with
the guns and that's the thing that's the
irony because we told we all talk about
guns guns guns but we don't really like
our police carrying big big guns you
know big solid guns many guns in the
United States it would be impossible to
imagine the u.s. police not to be armed
oh they do yeah but we don't see it
that's the thing that's the I am because
you know I've never seen a gun and we
talk about guns but if you're a
progressive individual I wasn't even
allowed to have a toy gun that's how
progressive my family was so that's why
I get on edge when I see them and that's
why we went to airports and train
stations it's just like wow you guys are
ok with this you know well of course we
have had a terrorism problem much
greater than the United States which has
has probably some spectacular events of
course 9/11 being the the worst of them
but on the European mainland and in
Britain we have had really 20 years now
of of serious terrorist violence yeah
all right George well that's that's all
I had great job team we'll talk to you
from Sacramento a lovely lovely place I
have very fond memories of it let's go
to North Carolina and talk to mark mark
welcome hey Tony jerk good morrow
I was thinking Georgian beginning just
talking about all Russia and all that in
this new scam that they're trying to
push up I'm ready you know I
animosity against Russia's it's actually
borders and racism I won't say it's
racism because you know I would watch it
being election is not a race
but it's some kind of ism because but it
really goes back I think hundreds of
years because you could even see for
instance like World War two and like
Patton would say are you not only these
commie so you also saw that these
Mongols you know this is what it really
goes back back to because you know the
anglo-saxons I'm not just talking about
England I'm talking about the United
States you know they're basically the
ruling class a lot of the ruling class
the United States and Britain and even
to agree in other countries like Germany
Western Europe they really have
hostility toward Russia based on I think
on you that that threat from the east
you know yeah and it is so disgusting
well you know that was understandable
when the Soviet Union was an existential
challenge to Western capitalism and so
on it's much more difficult to
understand now that Russia is a
capitalist country more or less
operating the same kind of economy as
exists in Western European and North
American countries it's hard to get a
handle on that oh it goes but again
going back in the history if you look at
even do it in our civil war the Russians
he told them back down back off you have
to Crimean War back then actually
exactly which year but I mean it's been
a lot of hostility even well before they
became communist yeah that's a good
that's a good point
Britain of course invaded Russia Winston
Churchill was responsible for the
invasion we invaded Russia with hundreds
of thousands of British soldiers in the
Civil War after the Bolshevik Revolution
we occupied apart
Russia yeah nobody talks about that now
and yet that's the actual background you
know Russia never invaded us in fact it
helped us avoid a defeat in the Second
World War which would have meant the end
of us yeah sure would ally I don't think
we would have won world war two without
the Russians I'll be honest with you and
if you look at some what you're saying
about the invasion yet Americans is a
deter to any other and then a bunch kick
and exodus exactly will happen in a land
war in Russia today they would overpower
NATO in the proxy days because they are
defending their homeland and they've got
an excellent army ah
the only problem is he only doing I
would hate to see a bloodbath like that
first of all I don't want to see anybody
killed I don't want people war the other
thing the property wouldn't say Cain
went to avoid that bargain happening the
new construct lying happy and of mankind
probably me more exactly show us a call
of the night mark thanks very much for
making it David is in Bulgaria we're
getting around tonight go ahead David
good evening George go ahead yeah I want
to speak about racism and what people
actually imagine is a racist and the
word racism
the reason being I'm English I live in
Bulgaria do to basically financial it's
so cheap to live here I've also got a
house in Uganda so I've got Ugandan
black friends now there's two two points
behind this word racism I became
incensed today when I was on Facebook
and one of my friends on Facebook from
Uganda I had posted a program from the
British TV I don't know which one
because I don't receive British channels
here but then it was a journalist caused
a furor
we wish yeah with a nick Ferrari yeah I
don't know when this was recorded
queries no
yeah she was talking about she have seen
all the statues removed and she was fine
but she was British and it said her if
you don't like living here go back and
she scored another British as had been
here or her life yet when you look at it
on Wikipedia she's born in Norway so she
holds a British passport and that this
is one thing with the UK couple you
could be more than Norway and you could
have come to Britain that you know one
week old yes some someone telling you to
if you don't like it here go back that
is a racist comment it is I agree
but also if you look at the continents
around the world people from Africa
don't have an ethical passport I have
their own nationality when we play
football we have an English football
team there's no such thing as a British
football team and it really annoys me
that I have a British passport with our
English so you you're in favor of an
English breakaway no England part of
Great Britain part of the United Kingdom
you look at France as part of Europe but
they have a French passport it's not the
European passport well its borders ill
just Brazil doesn't have a South
American passport it has a Brazilian
Passport my wife is Ugandan like Ugandan
she has a Ugandan passport
why can't we have our own national
passport when we have it for sports
events hmm well we of course are the
Olympic Games have a British team yeah
but not in football we have England
Scotland why was you know even in
Buckley but the Olympic Games we have a
British team Team GB yeah I know when a
Scottish person gets the medal the
English people say we got it don't know
it thank you very much David fascinating
call from a man who lives in Bulgaria
and in Uganda
all kinds of people watching and
listening to the mother of all talk
shows 60-second break I promise
radio Sputnik
[Music]
tune in every Tuesday - loud and clear
for a regular segment called false
prophets a weekly look at Wall Street
and corporate capitalism where we talk
about the big economic issues of the
week from the point of view of working
people the poor and the u.s. position in
the global economy join us this Tuesday
and every Tuesday with financial policy
analyst Daniel Sankey right here on
radio Sputnik want to talk get in touch
with us at radio at Sputnik news calm we
are talking twenty four hours a day
seven days a week you are listening we
give you the most essential out of the
endless information space radio Sputnik
telling the untold
[Music]
radio Sputnik we speak your language
find us at Sputnik news calm 24 hours a
day seven days a week we give you the
most essential information out there
radio Sputnik telling the untold George
Galloway and the mother of all talk
shells and join us at the College of
knowledge where there are no tuition
fees would trump supporters peacefully
accept defeat at the polls a yes
37% down one be no sixty-three percent
up one you can vote until the end of the
show on my Twitter feed at George
Galloway official George Galloway
bluetick in response to the poll Stephen
says I just can't see Biden beating him
in the first place once they have the
live debates Trump will destroy him
Biden can barely finish a sentence these
days but Stephen water on any live
debates
what if Biden says because of the
coronavirus I ain't doing any live
debates mark says Trump is already
lining up excuses if he does lose I have
no doubt his supporters will take to the
streets probably armed and Brett says
what will the Dems do if Trump wins not
recognize the election outcome they are
psychologically unable to lose to Trump
a second time very good point Brett and
the UN says thanks George dr. horn was
one of the best guests ever which he
taught me history in school yes indeed a
fantastic guest Vincent is in High
Wycombe in England let me talk to him
next
go ahead Benson hi George good yeah I'm
doing well thanks I'll talk about the
China corner firings okay since you're
gone China has 1.4 billion people and
they're very were reported a little over
3,000 deaths yeah
and UK has 67 million and any Colin T
dr. Randi bra is about 65,000
yeah 65 healed excess deaths in 2020
yeah yes so you really believe the
Chinese numbers I do and it's 1.4 it's
the British numbers I don't believe it's
the British government is the British
government that I've been lying about
the numbers all along if not for the
Financial Times you would not know that
65,000 number
yeah but how can they not down 1.4
billion well the Chinese response to the
corona virus simply doesn't compare with
our response they use the character
special character of their society for
good or ill you may like it suspect you
don't or you might not like it but they
use the fact that they are able to
marshal mobilize massive resources and
take from the centre very severe
measures to completely lock down entire
cities forbid anyone to leave them
anyone to enter them they disinfected
the streets every day they tracked and
traced are they tested they used the
strengths of their society to destroy
the coronavirus they still have cases
that every now and then erupted some of
them most of them are from people coming
in Chinese people coming back to China
about some of them are as it were coming
from inside China itself about mile
march China Vietnam South Korea
Singapore New Zealand at these countries
which as you love gathered are both
racially and ideologically diverse have
been success stories Britain and America
have been a catastrophe
no we're not to tear apart you but the
United States government
she said I again I didn't catch that
Vincent dr. Debra Burke
no I don't know her no tell me about she
said even when you're the clear of a
cause of death
they still put it down have closed it
you're one of these deniers missing
higher like she's happy in the press
confirm I've never heard of us so I
don't know I'm not I'm asking you are
you are you a denier a technical you
mean bottom are you are covered 19
denier
I'm not sure well what's your point that
that the corona virus is not nearly as
bad as we're being told there is often
we should be skeptical skeptical of
government figures yeah well having the
right place to be skeptical in Britain
anybody that believes what the British
government tells them I've got a
here in London I can sell them thanks
Vincent let's go to Brighton Henry is
there on Kirsten go ahead Henry I like
your shine yeah quite quite beyond the
shot really didn't expect cool back to
be on this Thank You Pierre on Kirsten
and they Rebecca long Bailey affair de
varville whatever you want to call it
yeah I must admit I've not done my
research I haven't watched all or looked
at the interview that might seem peak
herself that excuse me from what I
gleaned from what I've seen is that the
whole sort of crux of it was around the
Israeli forces teaching the American
forces the neck on the knee or neck
technique which you know I can see you
know it doesn't that would seem like a
bit of a big leap in I mean I do with
that actually I would not have put that
in the article if I had written it how
does I want to know George is how on
earth does that stand up as anti swell
is the point it absolutely does not and
and palette how could you know the
enough this is on a wider point I
believe that Kirsten is well let's not
get too paranoid but it's not far off a
lack of tolerance trying to I mean I
really like Nicole I think a continental
is a Greg a deal from Belfast a first
call oh yeah yeah sighing I don't know
much about Irish politics but talking
about the power vacuums and it seems
that that's what this world is finding
one at the moment and this country we're
going towards a complete power vacuum
with it you know we there's no it's not
it's not over yet Henry the point on the
factual matters are are these the
American police forces do go to Israel
for training that is an indisputable
fact not an opinion
yeah the Israeli security forces are
exceedingly brutal towards the
Palestinian people whom they are charged
with occupying and and repressing that
is an indisputable fact Israeli police
and security forces have choked people
with the knee on their neck now it would
not be unsure accurate to see the
American police learned of the knee on
the neck while they were training in
Israel that would seem fanciful not
least because I don't think American
police need any lessons from anyone on
brutality I really don't I think they
knew about brutality long long before
they started going to night classes in
Tel Aviv so the facts are clear but the
point you make is the important one a
criticism of the Israeli police a
criticism of the Israeli government
of the Israeli army of the State of
Israel itself is not anti-semitic how
can it possibly be there are millions of
Jewish people in the world some of them
religious some of them secular who are
completely opposed to Israel as a
political state in and as far as I
understand it and correct me if I'm
wrong the Zionism is an idea or not a
race or a religion of course if you are
opposed to communism in the Soviet Union
now that didn't mean hated Russians you
could argue it meant you loved Russians
you wanted to free them from communism
so how come being opposed to Zionism
means you hate Jewish people
Jacob is in Nottingham go ahead Jacob
all right George big plan the best way
to deal with institutionalized racism
will be to burn down the central banks
which impose those systems well I'm
against burning down central banks and
Men favor of taking them over in the
interests of the people yes I don't
think it's possible the way that if
that's also the best way to deal with it
the burn and darkness are from scratch
no we can't have arson advocated on the
shore Jacob I'm sorry I'll have to say
good night tom tom is in Cumbria let's
go to Tom hi Georgia I just make sure
the annexation of see Jordan Valley in
the West Bank yes it looks like it's
there certainly making moves to do it
now because from Washington Tom they've
got a green light from Washington I'm
not sure about that on the ground Middle
East monitors said that they are closing
roads now
going from which sounds are in the west
side of the West Bank in such Jordan
Valley so they are restricting movement
now into the Jordan Valley of the
Palestinians yeah and obviously this is
a huge concern it's a massive breach of
international law and because part of
the ongoing cleansing of area state
which is a whole area around the hip on
the hills which is in the South the way
I've been going way up yeah go on Tom
you were talking about earlier see ya
Harry amazing all the emergency from
Apple Hills going all the way up to the
Jordan Valley so my main concern now
comes down to paragraph six in other
words how many Jewish people are going
to be in this area compared to the
Palestinians because if they do take
sovereignty of the area so it's part of
Israel then what's going to happen so as
Palestinians because we know in
Jerusalem particularly they want the
Palestinians out and they want the
majority of Jewish people there so this
is obviously gonna raise questions and
the mind of people that paying attention
of how are they going to be shifted out
because they have to be shifted out in
many ways and will this be literally
Bruce Lee people being actually changed
from the area I doubt that but you can't
rule out of course Israel began that way
eight hundred thousand Palestinians were
driven out of their homes their land and
never have returned and by a hundred
thousand has now become many many
millions many of them living as refugees
in neighboring countries some of them
has displaced people inside their own
country and millions scattered around
the globe from from north south east and
west so it has happened before I doubt
if that will happen because it probably
won't be
necessary for it to happen because there
are other ways of achieving it and you
alluded to some of them if you make life
sufficiently miserable and desperate for
people then you can without having to
mother them you can move them along and
that is of course the $64,000 question
if you take the population of Israel and
the population of Palestinians living in
the inside the green line in Gaza in the
West Bank
the numbers are virtually exactly the
same so Israel is currently ruling
approximately 14 million people only
half of whom are is really only half of
them are Jewish and the other half are
not the other half are Christian or
Muslim and yet Israel insists that it is
not just a Jewish state but the Jewish
state and that is a problem as long as
the Palestinians maintain population
parity with our with a vote inside the
green line or without a vote just under
occupation and siege that's going to be
an ongoing problem
it requires an apartheid solution
because you cannot possibly give the
people who are as numerous as you there
are full civil rights their human rights
the right to vote the right to go to
court and so on you can't do that and
maintain your health no supremacist
concept of your state as a Jewish state
the Jewish state so it requires at some
point somehow either by a stroke of a
pen on a map or by some means to get
people out of your borders and that is
therefore pregnant with tremendous
dangers and the
can see that the world knows Tom that
this is a very serious step of that mr.
Netanyahu is going to take this coming
week and it's not just a breach of
international law egregious as that is
is a reckless endangerment of what
passes for equilibrium and if not peace
then the absence of war in the region
thanks for the call Bruce is in Darby
go ahead Bruce the world can see that
you're on the air all right George
welcome to the show yes welcome welcome
Yes Mother I say 48 when I was talking
to you about an you know the for Life
program and what's happening to you know
temporary workers yes but while I was
ringing up tonight to talk to you about
was you led to shake with asking about
if opposed to a labor policy yeah and I
think there is I think there is but I
think that's that's not a bad thing
because now the Socialists in the Labor
Party can realize that we don't need to
Tory parties and they can all come to us
Carly well it's a is making the labor
party a Tory Plan B and it's working the
the newspapers have fallen in love with
Kirsten the the broadcaster's have
fallen in love with him
Laura Ellsberg is looks to me literally
to be in love with them and so the
conclusion you can reach us that if push
came to shove the British establishment
would not mind getting rid of Boris
Johnson and replacing him with circus
farmer because as they said on the death
of Calvin
Coolidge as Dorothy Parker said on the
death of Calvin Coolidge how could they
tell how could you tell the difference
between a conservative and a Labour
government of the type that Kirsten are
clearly I would introduce Bruce thanks
for the call got a press-on Nicky is in
Paris go ahead Nicky hi George
I'm calling first of all great show I
watch it every Sunday I love it and I'm
just calling about the press for the
freedom of the press and the DSM a
system I've been looking at that
recently because I'm a supporter of
Julian Assange and since we've all been
wondering about the media blackout and
the media lies I contacted the DSM a
people for people who don't know what
the SMAS is the defense and security
media advisory we refer to it here as a
D notice yeah so it's also known as it
yet do you notice and so I contacted
them to get information about the
notices they've issued in respect of
anything published by Julian or
WikiLeaks and they wouldn't tell me even
though it's supposed to be a voluntary
system and then I discovered you're
going to have a good laugh because you
said they're more like Austin Powers and
mr. Beene you're going to have a good
laugh I found all that information on
Wikipedia so for your viewers who want
to see what sort of notices have been
issued they could go to Wikipedia DSM a
and they will see a list from 2000 and
between 2004 and 2005 after the Iraq war
the first one that I came across there
on wikipedia says that three blanket
letters were sent to newspapers advising
against publication of countermeasures
used against roadside ambushes of
British forces in the Iraq war so it's
it's been quite consistent since 2004
then there was another one in 2009
another one 2010 specifically about the
website WikiLeaks then another one 2013
about the US presence of prism
surveillance program another one in 2013
over NSA and GCHQ leaks so they've been
concentrating quite heavily another one
2017 they've been quite active with DSM
they have naked my first response would
be I would have been happy if the
British media had imposed a blackout on
the Julian Assange case because that
would have meant that we would have been
spared the ocean of Filth and
disinformation about Julian Assange that
we've been tilted to in the British
media I don't believe that there is a D
notice on the Julian Assange case and
here's why you'll be familiar perhaps
with the old adage but not everyone will
thank God you cannot bribe or twist the
average British journalist but when you
see what unbraid he'll do you realize
there's no reason - there's no reason
for ad notice to get the British media
to behave like Pavlov's dogs they do
that because they are the scorpion
stings because it's a scorpion and the
British journalist with only a very very
few honorable exceptions is quite happy
to be a hireling quite happy to be told
to micturate on Julian Assange or on any
one of a hundred targets from Tony Benn
through Arthur Scargill through Ken
Livingstone through me through many many
others and Julian being the most serious
seriously affected they're quite happy
to do it it's in their nature
to do it so there's no need as I say to
look for a conspiracy here because a
conspiracy is unnecessary I wasn't
looking for a conspiracy sure and they
are pernicious thing but by and large
they're not necessary because they may
not be our media is controlled by the
very lowest of people I agree I mean
you've seen the case this week
of Richard Desmond the owner of a
pornography Empire and the Daily Express
and the Sunday Express and the Daily
Star until very recently he's in a lot
of trouble now on a corruption case an
allegation of corruption involving a
government minister that's the kind of
person that owned and controlled an
important part of the British
journalistic architecture Rupert Murdoch
don't get me started on him we can go
through them all they are they are
reptiles and so they behave like that
I agree but what is to be done that's
that's the question to be done one thing
that we can do and you and I have just
done is expose it talk about it and we
have done that I think in a powerful way
thanks very much indeed Nicky for that
call I've only got a couple of minutes
left concerned father says does it
matter the social breakdown in the u.s.
is going to happen regardless which
senile old man takes office the
President of the United States doesn't
run the country the broken system does
and Scott says I voted yes I think it's
unlikely but if it doesn't happen then
you'll have a serious problem a
revolution or reactionary change in the
USA and on Twitter
Laura says darling gorgeous Gorge while
formerly whatever makes you think Trump
the buffoon is going to lose to the
prevented sleepy I think she meant
perverted sleepy Uncle Joe
I'm not seeing you well but on current
polling of course he is going to I've
got time for one last call Richard in
Manchester go ahead Richard good evening
George thank you very much to take him
out caller be as quick as possible
because you've got a great show on
tonight and I want to talk about Kirsten
adjust for just for just one second I
don't think in my opinion he has a hope
in hell of ever becoming the prime
minister but because of the people at
the back of him they will push the his
narratives of whatever he does in the
main stream media because of their hate
for Boris Johnson I'm sure that that is
well established now I'm sure millions
of people in the country realize what is
happening but I don't think you will
ever become a Harold Wilson I don't
think he'll ever become a prime minister
in this country to equal anything that
we've ever had I think he's too wouldn't
I'm not yeah I mean not only I'd agree
with that Richard but Boris Johnson is
really quite unpopular now and even in
his own party and even amongst many
conservative voters so I wouldn't rule
out the possibility that Kirsten Maher
will be facilitated in winning an
election but my point would be what
difference would that make
you'd have some more interesting jovial
bark replaced by a block of wood but
both of them following essentially the
same policies unless of course sir kia
is going to try and take us back into
the european union that would be a
genuine difference and one which would
not be to Kirsten Maas advantage
electorally sorry that call was so short
Richard but I had literally have run out
of time
got 14 seconds to say for me it's been
marvelous I hope it was also for you and
if it was to come back next week at the
same time in the same place and bring
another listener or another viewer with
you
[Music]